let's listen to it together
and and see what it what it's about
david jimmy from philly i'm sick and
[ __ ] tired and listen to your
[ __ ] about unhinged trump supporters
and this and that
put yourself forward
that's all for you you can't you
you you can't withstand it david
my information [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccino
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccino
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccinos
[Music]
[Music]
flippy from indiana flippy from indiana
please unmute you are on the air my
friend hi can you hear me
yes i can
hey david it's me um i just was
wondering if you've ever reconsidered
making an only benz sorry if i if i've
done making an omelette what no no
making it only fans uh you know uh
gardening season is over and it's time
for you to show us your zucchini
that's very clever no listen um i think
i'd be more likely
uh i'd be more likely to show my my
granny smith apples than any zooks
floppy dukes flippy floppy uh floppy
dukes
floppy dukes flippy floppy uh
five and a quarter inches
in the name of jesus from south america
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here they're coming here
from africa
i hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of victory i hear the sound of
winning winning winning
winning winning
[Music]
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
[Music]
dumps
big massive dumps
[Music]
dunks dumps dumps
dumps
[Music]
donald trump insisted multiple times
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election which is just
they call them dumps dumps dumps dumps
rushes out to sea
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times as opposed to once
dumps dumps dumps
dump big massive dumps dumps dumps
[Music]
what is going on here
[Applause]
so
[Music]
all right welcome everybody uh we have a
big big stream for you today
mike pillow is now speaking in coleman
alabama where there are some trumpists
uh oh they've strategically placed
blacks for trump um in the spot where
they always do there are people who
believe
that donald trump will actually be
reinstated at this rally either secretly
or overtly
i don't know but uh it's all going to be
happening today uh also
apparently they're expecting absolutely
huge dumps of rain they call them dumps
um a big thunderstorms in the area
there's even a report which we'll get to
that they had to stop metal detector
usage
because of um
thunderstorms in the area or something i
mean so so anyway we're expecting large
amounts of rain and it will be extremely
wet from the standpoint of water one of
the wettest we've ever seen from the
standpoint of water exactly and that is
going to be all coming up today
this is live this is a live stream
people asking about whether we're live
yes we're live
do you think this is a rerun or
something like that maybe it is but
um okay so what and let's just have a
great stream okay guys i have a full
agenda um why meb just gifted 10
subscriptions on twitch and small fuzzy
moss who provides many many of these
audio drops actually came from a small
fuzzy moss
re-upping on twitch and margot cabot is
here with a sub just seeing a lot of
great friends rage and tater
cold press juice box
kicking us off already at 14
which is just on another level
and
just so many things to talk about i will
tell you right now i have no unban
requests so we can just kind of put that
aside i don't know that we need to deal
with that
um because i just have no unban requests
i do have 457 new voicemails though
and maybe if we're lucky
we'll uh we'll get to a few of them
let's just listen to 30 seconds of mike
pillow just out of curiosity but we have
a very full full plate today all of this
stuff is getting revealed and i'm
telling you we're gonna get through this
is the greatest time in history to be
alive because i'll tell you what when we
get way out here
and they pull this election down and all
this stuff when we get out to a place
that's glorious you're gonna look back
and you're going to see every single
thing that had to happen just the way
god intended it
and
and we will once again be one nation
under god
blacks for trump reacting strongly uh
you can see here i don't understand
whether they say
hey send someone from the group with the
shirt and we'll put them on stage
or i don't know how it all happens but
as you can see
um black folks dramatically
overrepresented on the stage right now
relative to their rate of support for
uh president donald trump also known to
many as prompt then he went donald trump
yeah donald trump
uh okay so so a lot's happening here i
do want to say thank you people just
dumping memberships in will woodruff and
rosie have signed up jen here just
gifted five and mikey gaming gifted one
calamid 67 just signed up
uh now i'm going to say this the way we
say it in argentina el porcho
pocho diablo has grabbed a membership
that's another nine putting us at 23
and yes phone lines will open will open
at 100 today we've not done open phones
for a while
um let's see
oh okay people asking about what's going
on with jimmy from philly appearing with
me and dr k dr alok eloquenoja for an
intervention dr k has graciously agreed
to do a session with jimmy from philly
so maybe we can figure out how did he
become an alcoholic how did he become a
racist how did he become ignorant um
i've not heard back from jimmy from
philly that's actually the delay now so
if people want to go jimmy from philly
has a youtube channel if people want to
go
to that channel and let him know please
respond to david pakman because they're
trying to get you on we're trying to do
an intervention with dr k
so uh
i think it would be absolutely fantastic
um so anyway
please please please please
we also now are able to do polls on
youtube live
let me see here create a poll i'm gonna
do it so let's let's try this if we can
guys hold on a second i'm gonna create a
poll on youtube moderators please create
one on twitch so we can have the same
poll going back to back the poll is
going to be
uh
oh i created a blank poll hold on
what's going on here maybe it's not as
easy as
the kids these days okay here we go here
is going to be the poll question
um
will trump
cut
speech short due to
thunderstorms tonight okay yes no
and then the third option is sir all
right so i'm asking the community please
replicate this over on twitch
um
okay and where's the poll oh there it is
most people think the answer is sir
all right well i don't know how much
that tells us sir your wife is up in the
air
um
but we're monitoring that okay so that
that that poll is happening over on uh
youtube but i would love if the
moderators could help me replicate it
over on the on the twitch side
uh it doesn't seem like that's happening
right now but that's okay
that's okay
thanks to badness as well as uh d
patterso and d hoop poop nico
uh toyle just gifted five already
putting us at 32. oh wait a second no
yes 32.
um and if you're just joining us i i
don't know how many of you missed our
16th anniversary but on monday we had
our 16th anniversary at the david pakman
show which is really an historic event
and we did a a membership discount um
the code is 16 for 16. you know you can
imagine what the discount is that's one
six for one six and you can use that at
joinpackman.com
which is fantastic all right so i would
love if people have been thinking ah
maybe i'll sign up for one of those
memberships one of these days this one
is uh
borderline criminal
and certainly immoral which i know
excites a lot of people 16 for 16 1-6 fo
r16
people already misspelling it so we
tested the poll
um
let me oh let me look at a few super
chats i i do people have been asking me
to comment about the hassan destiny
[ __ ] the second house situation i do
have thoughts on it and i'll comment on
that in a moment
atari dc asking via super chat pizza or
meth which is the cheaper debate tactic
i don't even know what that means
pizza or meth
jane woman power says you look well
rested and recharged yeah you know i'm
actually still jet lagged and there's
two different things going on as far as
jet lag is concerned i came from i was
uh i traveled you know i i was in the
air sir your wife is up in the air and i
flew over six time zones
and you can basically adjust one time
zone a day i've been back four days so
i'm still kind of off by two hours but
the other thing that's been going on is
because i've just been home i had to
jump right back into work and stuff
basically like i got up at 4am on
wednesday i just felt wide awake it was
like i've never taken adderall but i
said this must be what people on
adderall feel like it was 4am and i was
just paying
because it felt like like 10 a.m to me
and then i went to bed early so then i
still got up at like five the next day
and six today i was up at 6 15. so i'm i
i think i'm hurting my readjustment by
not getting back to my normal schedule
it's like i'm just i'm just
yeah you know okay so anyway that's
what's been going on
my worst trade deal possibly of all time
okay denver mccarthy says david would
you eat dinner with wacky voicemail lady
for 10 grand if your personal safety was
guaranteed dessert would be non-optional
uh if they had flan
panna cotta tiramisu or chocolate babka
for dessert
yes i would do it
okay
that's those are basically the
that's the situation i do want to say
thank you to jennifer olds for signing
up on my website just now brand new
member also alexandru deku has just
signed up at joinpakman.com
and then first person using the
anniversary discount code 16 for 16
tonight chase maxwell has just signed up
putting us at a really strong 35 right
out of the gate
other super chats marjorie taylor pacman
says imagine waking up to realize you've
been in a coma or a comma for six and a
half years trump never ran covet never
happened bernie just announced his 2016
campaign yeah good it's true okay
that would be something
sir when you departed europe for the usa
did you have even the slightest feeling
you were leaving sanity for insanity yes
especially since cases are down in spain
like 55
or something like that
um i was going from cases up to cases
down which doesn't feel great here's the
u.s and as you can see that's not a
curve that you want
on the other hand spain
or espana as we say with a beautifully
reductive reducing curve it's not
reductive it's it's reducing it's
diminishing
um
yeah
so i did feel
like i was doing exactly that
matthew says blacks for trump rolling
into the event straight from central
casting yeah i really don't know whether
the blacks for trump thing is a um
whether whether it's you know whether
it's essentially actors or what it i
just have no idea
are you bummed because you missed out on
the only fan's cheddar you would have
made bank bud yeah exactly
um sos cuba former trump voter glad to
have found the light glad to have you
here
are you doing this broadcast from prison
yes this is my jumpsuit color
sir f your espresso as well glad to join
your group moved here to the philippines
two years ago appreciate you being able
to d this show john u.s coast guard
retired thank you john
did you see portions of the border wall
were destroyed by monsoon rains yes
i did see that
ironic
came from frankfurt on wednesday same
feeling i came from frankfurt on tuesday
yeah
i went to a great place in frankfurt
called naive with two dots over the eye
beautiful pizza
i'm kind of baffled mike pillow has been
able to keep the grift going he's due to
grow broken due to go broke and burn out
at some point right i would think so i
would think so
let me say a big thank you to zach
moriarty who just signed up on my
website with the coupon code 16 for 16.
also want to say thank you over on
twitch to pokestate
andrew dale
no andrew dale did not sign up sorry
green sin poke state
tatted reaperous
um toil just gifted five subs the ryan
the ryan goat just signed up
jalunit is a new member
putting us at uh 44.
we could set a record today guys this is
going crazy
all right let me address the hassan
destiny [ __ ] the second thing so listen
hassan bought a 2.7 million dollar house
i got a bunch of tweets people going
crazy david please comment on it
what do you really want me to say guys
you know i mean it's like listen first
and foremost i think that
it's a thing so there's two sides to
this okay there's hassan's a socialist
and he bought an expensive house
let me address that first okay
um
if you think taxes should be higher
but you're still paying the tax rate
assigned to you
i don't think that's hypocritical
you sending in more tax money
isn't policy okay and you could be
saying i think people in my tax bracket
should pay more in taxes
but i'm not going to be the one guy just
sending it in because that's not the way
that policy works
and similarly you know hassan talks
about we should decommodify housing or
whatever i don't know exactly what what
his position is but once when we spoke
he mentioned something like that
and he got an expensive house because he
can afford it
okay so what's the big deal he could
still believe that we him buying an
expensive house
doesn't change
the the
the progress towards
decommodifying housing and then lastly
you're sending him money right people
are sending him money if you you know i
don't know how many people think
oh tom cruise is in a movie the movie
seems really cool
but he has too much money i'm not gonna
go and pay 17 bucks
to watch the movie at a theater well
that's not usually how people think if
the two hours of entertainment are worth
17 bucks then you go and you go to the
movie and i think it's similar and and
then here's the other thing
anybody who has at the you know once
you're at a certain level of of audience
on youtube slash podcast slash
twitch and that you know include whoever
you want in that right i mean listen
we're almost at a billion views
i think just people make more money than
many in the audience believe
and
i don't know what to make of that you
know it's like uh
don't contribute
i i don't know what else to say so i
don't really have too much to say about
it
um
most people you know uh you know at a
certain level of success you you buy a
house and the house is more expensive
than the average house my only surprise
quite frankly was that hassan didn't buy
it through a trust
and legal eagle responded to me
by saying well in california to buy it
in a trust you've got to put like 50
percent down
and it's all these uh that may be true
in california i don't know and if that's
the case i mean listen i'm very
financially conservative
so
like i've i
live below my means and have an
extremely high savings rate um it sounds
like if that's not something hassan was
able to do maybe maybe this is a more
expensive house than he should be buying
but that's a personal finance question
that's not a policy question or whatever
else but yeah i mean i uh you know
myself and many others
we we i use a trust for real estate
both for really for privacy and i i'm
like how are all these articles being
written you know the dave rubin house
purchase the jimmy dore house now hassan
destiny [ __ ]
um it's surprising to me that more
people aren't availing themselves at
that level
and uh do it through a trust do it
through a trust okay
please
um all right what else do we have here
i want to say thanks to stacy male for
signing up with the coupon code 16 for
16. catherine killingsworth is a new
member
paige foshee is a new member and esther
weatherly is a new member putting us at
48 we did hit our 16th anniversary on
monday we celebrated this with a
discount code if you've been thinking i
kind of like david don't evaluate my
financial situation okay just if you
think what i do is of some value to you
where you would pay a dollar 60 a month
then you have a coupon code available
right this is the same thing as as with
hassan
um it's just if this is worth a dollar
60 a month or 16 for the year you can
use our 16th anniversary code um
one six four one six sixteen for sixteen
one six for one six
and you can get a grossly discounted
membership i mean just absolutely it's
pathetic actually how discounted it is i
shouldn't even be discounting it this
much i believe it could even be a
violation of hipaa
to discount memberships to this degree
okay um
let's see
okay let's go through a few different
things that i have here actually
uh
just to get caught up we are very close
to a billion views on youtube we are at
900 this actually isn't updating in real
time i think we're at like 9.92
we have had a blockbuster just
blockbuster couple of days
where we've been doing a million views a
day very strongly and so we could be
hitting that billion view mark sooner
than you might imagine that's number one
number two um
oh number two
i uh put together a drink today
um that is espresso with seltzer
all right check this out espresso
over ice
and then
seltzer
okay
excellent drink
highly highly recommend it i did get a
couple messages from baristas
uh or baristas as i call them and they
said
pour the espresso in at the end
because then it'll be extra sort of
foamy
um
quite good okay so that's that
what else do we have oh oh oh oh that's
why i had this so i posted this picture
during my trip
and a viewer of ours
um remixed it like this
wait a second
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's pretty well done i have to tell
you let me get one more look at it i
like that
[Music]
[Music]
i don't even know how that's done like
it's completely foreign to me how that's
even done
um okay so we got that
um let me make sure we're keeping up
with everything i do have other things
for you guys
oh whoa a bunch of memberships coming in
kate hodges just signed up using the
16th anniversary code heather murray
just signed up
zac zeitlin just signed up alexander
tatro as well as jordan mccormick all
taking advantage of the explosive coupon
code 16 for 16. also thanks to akira
loves ryuji
as well as data music
alice maravillas or as we say in
argentina marawishas
marvels
gordon z hall has signed up on twitch
jules cools is a new member shot x
thomas
jen here just resubscribed green sin is
a new member so that puts us eight
that's already putting us at uh 61
and then also on the website micah the
pica signing up and new member number
62.
really really appreciate it
um let's continue with some of my other
material here here is an interview i
love this guy donnie o'sullivan i
believe he's irish people can correct me
if i'm wrong he just does great
interviews with trump supporters and
part of this i don't know
what what it is
but the boom mic with the huge puffer on
it
on the boom i mean it
visually this is also
visually it's extremely well done
extremely extremely well done you know
there's parts of the country now where
you can't go into restaurants bars
unless you're vaccinated
i don't need the restaurants and bars
hell i don't drink i don't need to go to
a restaurant i go shoot my dinner yeah
just saying
i mean this guy seems fun huh there's
millions of guns here
you know it took 11 days for them to
take over afghanistan i wonder how many
days just ask for a friend how many days
did it take the patriots take over this
country think about it
you don't want that to happen here i
don't want it to happen but if our
country and our government and our
congress and biden them don't get their
heads out there but it's going to happen
i'm i assure you it's coming
okay
i'm not vaccinated and i'm not going to
get vaccinated our days are numbered it
don't matter whether it's coveted or i
can get in that truck and go down the
highway and get hit by a semi t-bone and
kill it don't matter t-bone you know
life is what it is you know we take it
how god gives it to us but you are a
seat belt right
of course
oh that is good of course yeah maybe i'm
not crazy i'm going to do something i'm
going to reduce my risk obviously he's
not insane 1950 chance that'll save you
it won't save you sort of like a vaccine
right that's certainly taking a vaccine
you take the steps yeah to protect
yourself when you can't no no no it's
nothing like seat belts and vaccines
there's nothing similar i mean okay both
are measures which statistically are
likely to reduce harm although they are
not guaranteed to work and they're
available and you've sort of got to be
an idiot to go out of your way to avoid
them but they're not really similar in
any other way
so that's that
um here's a quick rudy giuliani clip
rudy says um
that
impeaching biden would be logical and
something about being unfit for office
here's rudy rudy looking gaunt by the
way
the grassroots impeachment are one of
the most basic that hamilton lays out
the federalist papers and that is when
he's uh
when he is acting in violation of his
constitutional responsibilities in this
case to protect us and
uh make certain uh that what's really
even talking about we have peace and
prosperity he's acting in violation of
his duties to uh save american citizens
and finally it really i think is a
better case for 25th amendment better
but i would pursue an investigation of
both
i begin an investigation whether there's
grounds for impeachment remember you got
to do that first and second i begin an
investigation of whether there's grounds
to remove them for
unfit for office all right so there's
rudy's opinion
um here is owen schroer now hopefully
you have forgotten completely about
infowars and alex jones
a friend of the show ethan klein from
h3h3 productions posted this owen
shroyer
he now is going to be surrendering to
authorities apparently on monday
he is uh being charged multiple counts
it for his alleged involvement in the
january sixth trump riots here is owen
shroyer explaining this during uh alex
jones uh infowars the deal
ladies and gentlemen
a couple hours ago
i was informed by my attorney
yeah
that there is a warrant out for my
arrest
with allegations
involving
january 6th right
and i will have to turn getting very
real very quick guys very real very
quick for him turn myself in
monday morning right
uh there's a lot of questions yeah some
i have answers to some i don't
i'm not going to be getting into more of
this today on the air
really shouldn't even be on the air
right
and
i plan on
declaring
innocence of these charges he's going to
be declaring innocence
don't you plea innocence
because i am and so there's some other
stuff going on too
but uh that's the deal
and so i i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
comment any further on this i'm not
gonna take any questions on this today
do they even take questions like i don't
know i'm not super familiar with
infowars but it's funny to talk about
he's acting like everybody's going to be
asking him to comment on the show
do they even take who would even
possibly ask him it's weird
but again i was informed by my lawyer
that there's a warrant out for my arrest
right now and that i have to turn myself
in by
monday morning
so
uh that's just that
probably shouldn't even be on air right
now there you go okay so he gets to the
same conclusion i got to
uh which is you you really shouldn't be
on the air
uh we're keeping an eye on the trump
rally trump scheduled to speak any
moment now
um so we're keeping a very very close
eye on that let's continue
here is uh i guess this is just ominous
having weather issues at the rally
one of the wettest we've ever seen from
the standpoint of water
then we have um
here is oh here's a complete lunatic
being interviewed
before the uh
before the the thing today this is just
crazy check this out listen carefully
he's already here he's he never left
he's already he's the 19th president of
the republic
trump you're talking about right yeah
scripture
is there anything is there anything
specific you want him to address tonight
yes i would like him to explain what he
meant when he said his wife referred to
him as sir i want to addre him to
address when he's going to come forth
and say i am so that everybody will wake
up and we can get this country back the
constitutional republic of 1776. these
people are so so deluded it's it's
really crazy
that's what i've and it will happen soon
because god is in this and god wins
god
uh
powerful powerful statement
in the meantime um anti-vaxxers who
don't trust the vaccine
are getting uh a dewormer meant for
horses
and
taking it and they're ending up calling
poison control
um
yeah i don't know that i need to say too
much about it
other than the bullet points here
the food and drug administration has not
approved ivermectin as a covid19
treatment that's important
livestock or animal formulations of
ivermectin are highly toxic in humans
okay
ivermectin may cause symptoms such as
rashes vomiting and abdominal pain
okay so don't do it folks don't do it it
is meant for horses it is meant for cows
it is meant for steer and heifers it's
for animals it's a veterinary element
okay
and uh yeah
don't do it
just don't do it i mean listen
if you believed you had horse worms in
you
then maybe there's an application for it
i think it's a parasitic
but it's for it's for animals right and
so like if you're a horse then you take
the ivermectin okay good we figured it
out
um
oh man we've got some crazy stuff going
on here
hold on a second
did 25 people just get memberships here
this is insane
uh jacob giganti just signed up on my
website that's number one
james miller number two
this is actually nuts
michael jeremy number three
michael laurie number four
andrew ginty is number five
beth franzak is number six on my website
lenny mccabe thank you for the
membership number seven
mark
garowatosky
is number eight
michelle plunkett is number nine
ian spider i like that name ian spider
is number ten
michael cloyne is number eleven
thanks to ali prugar number 12. kevin
vicente is number 13.
jeannie ryder new member number 14
angelina wright is number 15.
quinn p y
number 16 david cordova new member
number 17
micah the pica getting another
membership number 18 brett vanderveen is
19.
steven maude is number 20 and malen
miller is number 21 putting us at 83.
also let me just do something extra
someone who signed up under the name
dummy email just pledged a 100 bucks a
month on patreon
today patreon counts double okay so
instead of putting us at 84 it actually
puts us at 85.
why not it's a pacman miracle i also
want to thank folks over on twitch uh
including d-loms no diems diems who just
signed up
crystal drama free is a new member toil
just gifted five subs ireman gifted one
manny just resubbed
iri man gifted another
um and hedgehog has just subscribed
putting us at
uh 92
wow and trump's not even out yet
let's just listen to the sights and
sounds of cullman alabama a cultural hub
globally
utterless
uh people like
joe biden and nancy pelosi
and chuck schumer
this democrat trio doesn't want to make
america great again
they want to make america like venezuela
or like cuba
venezuela
i'm pretty sure that
geronimo venezuela was my babysitter
growing up venezuela that's interesting
tax dollars
what's this guy's first language right
venezuela that's not even an accent
ladies and gentlemen
i'm afraid that they want to
fundamentally change the way that we
know the united states of america as we
know it today
is he talking about the uh relief
pitcher
fernando valenzuela remember what was it
was he known as el guapo what was his
nickname do people remember that
you guys remember him
we can send a message that in 2022
that we can send the socialist democrats
and kick them out of washington
and you know what then we can make
america great again
we will take on communist china
under there by american plan like i'm
not making fun of southern accents but
this guy
does this guy speak nor
like normal english
because if this seems beyond an acc an
accent he just seems to not know
comments i mean it's bizarre
and manufacturers will be manufacturers
we cannot rely on any other nation and
especially china
where to make sure that we rely on our
day-to-day products
we will grow not shrink our united
states military
we don't need any more woke seminars for
our military
[Applause]
what i want yeah maybe he's uh he's got
novocaine
that's a possibility
i do want to say a big thank you to
joseph hill
dimitrios patarakis
and um
[Music]
morgan summerfield all of whom just
signed up on my website if you're just
joining us we had an incredible event on
monday it was called our 16th
anniversary and so we do have a great
membership special available to you
um and uh the code is 16 for 16. we do
an extra show every single day people
say sir why even sign up what's the
point of signing up well first of all
i'm helping hassan pay for his house so
i do need people to sign up so i can do
that but also we do an extra show every
single day
called the bonus show just for our paid
subscribers and uh no better time than
when we have a milestone like our 16th
anniversary it's just amazing all right
do people want me to go back to super
chat or do we want to delve into the 457
voi new voicemails that i have
what do people think
what would people prefer i mean i'll do
both but
voicemails all right let's do a couple
now you know what let me do a couple
super chats because i've fallen so far
behind
i can't even believe how far behind i am
here
um
david hope you had a lovely holiday
where in spain did you go on holiday i
have family from galicia i was in
galicia exclusively in galicia and then
i had one night in frankfurt
who will run against trump in the
republican party too early to say
2.7 million doesn't even get you that
much house in most markets these days no
that's not true two points in most
markets 2.7 million gets you a great
house you know there's some markets
where where um it gets you what in much
of the country is a normal house you
know los angeles uh boston new york
washington san francisco but no in most
of the country 2.7 million gets you a
pick of your of houses
hello from connecticut's second year
college student headed back to uconn
tuesday hopefully this rain will keep
the trumpers inside when he isn't
reinstated
yes
can you speak to when you think matt
gates will be indicted no as i've said
before i have absolutely no idea
no idea whatsoever
sir do you think trump will run for
president in 24 in an orange jumpsuit i
would love to see it
how did the crowd react when trump got
reinstated well it hasn't happened yet
it hasn't happened yet
former bernie voter now trump supporter
your commentary is half of what pushed
me over david watched you since 2011
you've gone corporate uh you sir are an
idiot
um even if it were true that i went
corporate which i would challenge you to
define why that would make you say i'm
gonna vote for trump instead of bernie
it's absolute idiocy so for your sake i
hope you're trolling
because it's completely idiotic
like not not liking this show means you
switch from bernie to trump
just stop watching this show but support
bernie it's bizarre it's giga cringe i
feel bad for you i hope it's a troll we
know you lie about your height but what
is your waist and foot size if i were a
betting man i'd wager 28 inch waist and
a size 8 foot no
sir you're very wrong um i am a
30 inch waist
and i wear a size 10 shoe
yeah
thanks for letting me join have you ever
interviewed mick west no but i am
reading the book scale by jeffrey west
just started the book it has nothing to
do with what you're asking about but
um let me say a few more thank yous
chris paxman
has just signed up with the coupon code
myhippa
van helsing boombox is a new member on
my website jason frazier
is a new member sheila haidle is a new
member
melinda simpson has just signed up
so has patricia language is that a real
last name language i've never heard of
that as a language as a last name i like
it
welcome to sherry lynn nicholas as a new
member
also ian rawlings has just signed up and
so has chris geiler chris geiler brand
new member putting us at 103.
also thanks to the one true fester for
the twitch sub also chef ramsay
and a folding chair have signed up via
twitch putting us at 106.
we're standing by for donald trump now
12 minutes
late um a couple more super chats
should lefties be doing more to show how
bad larry elder is how do you decide
when and how often to destroy someone
with facts and logic
i mean is larry elder does larry elder
even really have a shot in california i
it didn't seem like he did
hello david congratulations on your 1
billion views
hey that's weird i've never seen this
before it's like a super chat
is it that now when you resubscribe as a
youtube member you can send a super chat
that i've never seen this before
anybody know
it's interesting nonetheless
sean says would you call yourself a
manlet i don't even know what that means
david would you please say huge
do you plan on a pacman blitz arena 2021
yeah we may do another chess tournament
it's pronounced dhoni
love your show sir
thank you
david nobody in right wing media is
covering this and they are propaganda so
why are you this is how he won the more
you obsess about him the more the right
loves him greed no uh just no that
you're you're completely wrong on all
fronts
david sir do you have any book
recommendations i'm interested in
reading something tech related thanks
for all you do my friend tech related
i don't read a lot of tech stuff
um like i said i'm reading scale by
jeffrey west it's very good
uh
you might find um
the book about uh
elizabeth holmes
company theranose
bad blood by john kerry that's a great
it's sort of tech
um
yeah
not sure
if gotp take back the house do they
impeach biden
don't know won't go anywhere
marjorie taylor pakman says
uh declaring innocence from the
standpoint of guilty
if the gop were successful in enacting
the 25th amendment they would then start
taking credit for floating the first
black woman into the white house
yeah that that would be weird they
didn't allow umbrellas at the rally yeah
apparently not
hurricane kletrina is about to strike
alabama
i've been watching this for almost seven
hours now certainly six many highlights
dude in the wall suit was funny these
people are nuts stick at it dp thank you
fun fact the form of ivermectin has been
found to be cut into cocaine
so i've been told anyway cough cough
yeah very very well said
people asking when trump speaks 15
minutes ago it's it's you know we just
never know it's never clear how long
it'll be i'm hoping that the rain keeps
his speech extremely short that would be
fantastic
the pica has just signed up
via twitch i really appreciate that your
new member number 107 today we're going
to get to some voicemails now
i do want to say thank you to
taylor lovenshimer who just signed up on
my website with the 16th anniversary
coupon code 16 for 16.
appreciate that very much all right
let's uh let's dive into the to the
voicemails i am going voicemail by
voicemail my friends okay here we go
david i'd like to admit that i was wrong
uh jesse dalmore and fearing cousins
weren't a total disaster they were all
right i'm still not a fan of wrinkle
fire's channel though
that's right he did a decent job but i
didn't watch the jesse donald dong with
bonus shows because i started watching
the first one and it was so cringe i
couldn't get through it
but uh
other than that it was all right
congrats on your upcoming billion views
milestone love you david all right
thank you let's continue
hey david i like the idea of
kind of crank calling or even just
sneaking your name in you know with like
news channels
but um
just sneaking in david pakman
billion views
lacks pizzazz you need to come up with a
catchphrase like baba bowie people that
have never spent
you know
okay all right i think i understand uh i
think i understand
hey david uh emily from uh dc
uh i just wanted to
per your last video um about mentioning
um your show on other youtubers i just
wanted to
play this for you
now there was no press allowed but that
video was recorded by someone in the
audience who then sent it to david
pakman and uh he shared it online and uh
i guess i can kind of understand why
they didn't want press there uh they
wanted to provide a forum for marjorie
taylor green to spew her
incredibly irresponsible and dangerous
road
so i just wanted to share that it's
pretty cool
cool all right
yep that's pretty good that's pretty
good
hi david i was just looking at your
piece on uh
republican hypocrisy
and you know
it really
hypocrisy is just a specific type of
dishonesty
and really what you're talking about is
is uh
is a character flaw
yeah okay
hey david b dog here i'm reading an
article on vice saying that the mike
pillow is harboring tina peters who is
being investigated by the fbi in a safe
house
dog
if true will mike pillow be prosecuted
for this
all right thanks dog appreciate that
um
[Music]
some of these are not exactly
like
great content i guess i would say
uh let's say
my question is oh here's troy york
calling with insane background noise
why don't you have donald trump on your
show
um he's ensured there's such a godless
power to attack the man heavy
every day he attacks republicans all the
time he never have ryan defenders or jim
jordan or the other people ron desantis
and jim jordan are welcome here
absolutely anytime
hi this is corey from allendale alabama
it's not corey from allendale it's
really troy york again
uh david pakman i'm going to be at the
trump rally tomorrow
or i guess today
um i'm very excited i i guess today that
he called it 4 31 in the morning i'm
going to catch the former president we
should be current president but because
we had the election rigged and stolen
he was on the rick and bubba show um
never heard of it okay troy's media diet
is is certainly interesting but i've
never heard of any of
the shows that that he's watching let's
continue
so um
i don't know if you want to put this on
the air or not but i just um it's a
little late it's like a really weird
story
oh
so
um sometimes i get like cosmetics and
stuff from
jewish people they have like stands
all around like kiosks and malls and
stuff like that are you talking about
like the dead sea products or what like
amazing skincare regimen
so
i go
and i'm with my daughter and i go to one
of those stands this is a mom oh my god
and it's like
a jewish kid from
israel i think
all right we're moving on continuing
here
hey welcome back david
hey your co-hosts are those people
saying for you
uh the democrat party is the party of
the taliban they tell vandalism
and control through the democrat deep
state
um political action committee that is
actually
funded by saudi arabia and allied with
promoting islamic radical fundamentalism
um
the taliban are in control only because
of joe biden and the democratic party
who seeks to
empower the muslim radicals
um
all right then the chicago guy called in
you know i was thinking that
sir dp
about those that one guy who talks
really slow and is
he was commenting that
you didn't pay a whole lot of attention
about what
else could have been done and it just i
thought on it on hours and hours
and you're right i mean trump
somehow would have
somehow done it worse and then overall i
think we can all agree on that
but and you can't help i can't stop
thinking about what i would
you know if i was in that situation
without even without like a weapon
especially man i don't even know what
he's talking about here's another one
yes you admit the obvious i think the
the there
it was a republican who got us into this
20-year war
just probably like a republican i think
eisenhower i don't know i think who got
us from the vietnam all right here's
eric from mass who always has some very
specific criticism that it's often
doesn't apply to me
hey david it's eric massachusetts i'm
just wondering how you uh reconcile
your racism with the fact that um
businesses being able to deny service to
anyone who doesn't have a vaccine when
you know damn well or you're acting like
you don't 72 percent of the uh black
community is not vaccinated and you know
that i mean you know that so i'm just
curious as to why
and how you don't see that as racist or
as a second coming of segregation
very very painfully dumb voicemail
unfortunately
um yeah
welcome back from your vacation i hope
it was restful and i hope you're
recharged and ready to deal with the
nonsense that is the republican party
and conservatives in general
i agree with you 110 from what you just
said
listening to all the reasons why
republicans are hypocrites and that why
they lack any moral authority to preach
to anybody or to criticize anything
uh about anything that anybody does
other than themselves beautiful and in
fact
i often point out all these things to
republicans
time and again
love it this guy called right back
oh by the way you just show that video
of abbott clapping his hands singing
that stupid-ass texas song
deep in the heart of texas yeah i left a
message
uh actually two separate messages two
separate days on his machine all right
well that's different we i don't need a
report about that let's see what's going
on at the event it looks like now
they've brought kids on i i would i
believe bringing a kid to this counts as
child abuse thank you
oh is that this guy's kid
i thought that kid was just in the
audience that's funny oh but are there
other yeah there are some kids in the
background right
let's see what's happening here
[Music]
[Applause]
by the way
this right side broadcasting people are
dumping hundred dollar super chats left
and right it's crazy i mean no wonder
the right is so well funded are you guys
seeing this it's insane
hello coleman county
we got the best two things coming
we got
football coming right around the corner
and we got donald trump right back here
yeah all right so it seems trump will be
speaking soon i do want to say thanks to
book loving mom for re-upping
uh the twitch prime sub for the second
month remember twitch prime subs do not
automatically recur
you do have to do it manually i also
want to say thank you to my aziz dragon
for gifting five subs
menzies has also signed up that is
something else huh
that is six putting us at 115.
it was our 16th anniversary on monday we
have a code for that
and i want to thank people who have been
using it
linda lightcap just signed up on my
website with the code 16 for 16.
brian lc is a new member paid full price
kyle mclahorn
is a new member
lori why not has signed up
ruth kaufman is a new member
and michael vaughn has signed up putting
us at 121 very much appreciate that
let's look at a few more super chats
here
it's the david pakman show it's my
favorite show you do more good than you
know the david pakman show yeah let me
see if i can find some of those songs
um where do i have these is it in my
memes folder no
is it in media
no
is it in
where would it be
where would i have those
songs ah here we go
oh nope that's not it
where are those
documents no
archive i'm sorry i'm not able to find
it
could have sworn i had a folder for it
clips hold on
oh remixes oh here it is here it is
uh
which one of these was it
it might have been this one let's see
this brings back
memories it's my favorite show
it's my favorite show
[Music]
[Applause]
this one's great
[Music]
okay all right people get i think you
guys get it you get the reference good
does anyone know who's speaking right
now no
anybody know who this guy is in front of
him but he fought hard for all of us and
thank god he was up there for four years
now
i'm not going to go through all of the
things that he did you don't want to
hear me you're going you want to hear
donald trump you came here tonight to
hear donald j trump yeah
so
i just want to let you know
that
thanks for coming out here tonight right
um john says sir apparently you just
experienced a big membership dump
congratulations they call them dumps yep
take dewormer but not the vaccine it's
not approved yeah i actually tweeted
about that yesterday
uh where is my twitter here it
is where was it here let's see
uh uh yeah here it is the vaccine is not
approved by the fda so it's dangerous
and unnecessary anyway because we have
the monoclonal antibody treatment which
is
also not approved by the fda oh yeah you
were talking about the dewormer but uh
same gist same gist applies for sure
no oh i just lost that
hold on
take discord calls where did it go ah no
it's really alabama i was born and
raised here
i just got a promotion so this is for
you sir thank you
taking discord calls yes taking calls
later
last time i asked about raising a child
in argentina at the end you said you'd
need to ask yourself if it's the right
thing can you give us a three-minute
download on the challenges of argentina
i mean basically just
complete developing nation situation
outside of buenos aires and and a
handful of other major cities
completely bonkers hyperinflation
um
you know i mean it's it's all the things
you would expect all the things you
would assume i think
sir finkel is einhorn and einhorn is
finkel laces out yes a reference to uh
ace ventura so what are we actually
going to see here i don't know
i don't know will someone with trump
backing will run for president in his
standing it's possible
not a troll i legitimately think your
commentary is ridiculous enjoy the money
you corporate shill thanks i appreciate
that
i second you getting an interview with
mick west his ufo work is pretty bad and
dishonest his q and on work is brilliant
david we regret to inform you you have
been removed from the bd boys we're
sorry for the inconvenience
david sir larry elder has a disturbing
chance of winning vote no on recall
sorry i wasn't clear it's pronounced
dhoni o'sullivan not donny oh i see okay
okay um i want to say thanks to kay
guldi as well as galacticat and harry
proper dirty curta all of whom have
signed up via twitch we seem to be
getting down to the last speaker this is
mo brooks right
and i want you
to help me
give president trump a rather unique
alabama welcome what i call an iron ball
a welcome exactly i do want to say thank
you to some really important people
brennan fletcher just got a membership
on my website
sue manning henckley is a new member
nathan olsen welcome nathan
susan greenall has just signed up
and michael gerheiser is the newest
member putting us at 1 30
1 30. we're standing by for donald trump
um
why is it dark on the right and light on
the left is the left earlier or
something like that it's kind of a weird
no real explanation there
thanks to marina parapletchikova
pereplichukova i hope i'm pronouncing
that correctly marina i apologize you
are new member 131 today
folks wildly taking advantage
does anybody know who i am in the
audience or are people just coming by
with no idea of what channel this is let
me take a look
a lot of people subscribing so maybe
people
don't actually you just stumbled across
we've actually been doing this for a
while and we had our 16th anniversary on
monday
and so we have a coupon code 16 for 16.
and you can use it on my website and
it's crazy
it's just a crazy it saves like 70
something percent we've never done it my
lawyer is telling me to stop
my accountant is telling me to stop
hassan is telling me to stop he knows
that this is not the right coupon code
for houses
it's just not gonna work
um everybody's telling me to stop
but we're doing it anyway
and jackie wiseman just signed up on my
website
denise wrestler just signed up on my
website very much appreciate that
um
it's just the day if you've been
thinking oh i don't know you know this
show i mean it's not worth six dollars a
month it's not worth five it's not worth
four today is the day of 160.
that's really the day let's listen to mo
brooks here if this is mo brooks we have
the greatest military capability in
world history we are the beacon of
freedom for all
we are the envy of the rest of the world
envy
and we are not the greatest in world
history because we are lucky we are
great because our ancestors sacrificed
their blood their sweat their tears
their fortunes and yes sometimes their
lives for freedom i don't know who's
crazier the person who says this or the
person who likes it
wizard of frobaz says via super chat
if god decided the election as the trump
supporter indicated then there must be a
corresponding signed voter registration
for it no
thanks david
do you think you will ever play in
another pog champs
if they invite me i will play
and do you think i could ever get a
quick blitz game against you sometime
maybe yeah i don't know
david i just finished i alone can fix it
what did you think i haven't read it
haven't read it when will these idiots
wake up climate change equals jobs green
new deal equals jobs you want to appeal
to these idiots get them good paying
jobs there are tons of trade jobs
available thank you david big fan of the
show
very well said
you're funny today welcome back says
chris thanks chris
how's your girlfriend doing praying for
a quick recovery yes she's doing fine
she had two false positive coveted tests
false positive cova tests
false positive cova tests not actual
positives very very important and then i
see the disinfectant is there a way we
can do something like that
uh by
injection inside or
supposing we hit the body with a
tremendous uh very powerful light
apply
light and heat to
cure supposing you brought the light
inside the body donate plasma
convalescent plasma donate plasma today
please all right so that's my covid
routine my favorite one of all of those
actually is definitely this one
apply
light and heat to
cure
that's so insane it's just crazy
the previous sticker is a youtube thing
it just let me say hello for being a
member 21 months it's a one-time thing
well thank you 20 i didn't even realize
we had been on the youtube membership
beta for 21 months
or the gamma or any of it thanks nemo
nova very much appreciate it
hey david thanks for all the reporting
you've done what will it take for
republicans to go back to policy or is
it gone forever republicans will go back
to policy as soon as policy rather than
trolling will win them elections
as soon as they as soon as their uh
followers care about policy they will go
back to it
there doesn't seem to be a downside
right now for them
at least not at the local level
that's it why would they go to paul
which could be never
it could be never i want to say thank
you to monisha giddings monisha welcome
signing up on my website with the 16th
anniversary code 16 for 16.
also ricky marlow jr is a new member
jason lombard has signed up and tim
esser is a new member putting us at
137 today
137
we should be moments from donald trump
now 36 minutes late
denver mccarthy says i really want to
see a drunken boston caller sobriety
redemption arc i feel bad for the guy
it's a chicago it's a chicago guy not
boston
i would like to visit florida one day
not when covet is out of control
yeah i was in florida at the end of june
before it got completely out of control
and it was still pretty out of control
i kind of regret regret going
i'm from coleman but i've luckily moved
i am daily working to promote critical
thinking media literacy i love what you
do keep up the good fight thank you
i truly can't afford this as my husband
lost his job over a month ago
but you really have to talk about phil
valentine dying yeah i've been talk
we've been covered this anti-vaxx radio
host phil valentine has been sick with
covet and he's been getting sicker and
sicker he just died
um
it's it's it's sad i mean it's all sad
and he has become he became a vaccine
advocate
um
since getting hospitalized he died
he died today yeah if people haven't
heard so we will talk about that on uh
we'll talk about that on monday he died
of covet guys he died of covet
what do you think we're talking about
here
august is almost over when is trump
getting reinstated exactly i think
tonight
where's the glowing glasses meme oh yeah
somebody sent it to me
this should be the new format we need
memes okay
uh let me see here
uh where was it
david asked for i think it was now i'm
struggling to find it
oh here it is
so you can find this on our subreddit i
wore glasses on the last stream
and i did what we call bitcoin eyes
and i deliberately did it with the
reflection of the lights in my face
and um people did post it
if people want to turn this into various
me i think this is a great new meme
format okay so i'm going to paste this a
few times
in uh twitch chat
and then i'll paste it just a few times
in youtube
so the creative people in the audience
can get it yeah start sending those in i
think that would be great
um other super chats fox news is
currently showing live updates of a
chicago police standoff
love it thanks for playing that it's my
favorite show mix so good
yeah you know we actually had a couple
others
um that didn't quite well hold on a
second
see if i can get one here
show and file let's see here
uh here's one other one for you guys
it's crazy this is my full-time job
right
[Music]
all right so that was the art flores mix
psycho nadia i think was a good one
[Music]
[Music]
and then i think i have just one more
for you
[Music]
okay all right that one didn't win but
that's that's okay
hi david happy 16th anniversary love
your show keep up the woodwork good work
thank you maria i appreciate that
um
my entire family got kova decided to
take invermectin and hydroxychloriquin
won't take the vaccine though it makes
no sense yeah that makes no sense happy
16th
can't wait to see where you go now that
you can drive
which is girthier your wrist or your
biggest cuke
um i'm actually growing lemon cukes
which are round
so it's not it's sort of like a doesn't
apply type situation
did you know meet kevin is running for
governor yes i know i know i'm up for
talking to him about it
if you didn't know david was in the uv
light room at the airport make sure he
didn't have coved
thank you master trump exactly
supposing we hit the body with a
tremendous
very powerful light
apply light and heat to
cure
swami live says supposing you donated
plasma convalescent plasma to apply heat
to cure
i'm just looking out for you and your
girlfriend thank you
sir do you think afghanistan will hurt
biden in the midterms or will it blow
over i think it has a real possibility
of uh hurting him sir i don't know yeah
usa is definitely not the envy of the
world hello from australia love the show
thank you
jesse dolimore and farren did an
excellent job sir tell us about your
decision to have us have them sit in for
you
i just i thought they would be i thought
they would be good that's all
um
thank you for all you do says cindy lee
did you hear about the british guy that
got stuck in afghanistan he traveled
wanting adventure i did not hear about
that no
i keep getting distracted by the guy
sign in the back that's cut off and says
save erica who is erica
yeah i see that
all right i'm somehow caught up on super
chats i can't believe it but we have
gotten ourselves caught up on super
chats all right we're standing by we're
probably moments from trump
somehow about 15 new memberships just
dumped in look at this tim allington
just signed up on my website what a day
james dickerson is a new member
dorothy murray just signed up
stefan
korkaz is a new member
mack hicks just signed up as did adam
smallowitz
thanks to aaron marshall for the new
membership and rebecca claycombe rebecca
thank you great to see you
chris joyner is a new member as well as
marty kopka that's ten more
nick scott just signed up as did michael
jules ii
alex griffis just signed up as well as
christopher ryan that's 14 and then
kenneth gish number 15
putting us at 162 people asking what's
the record the record is in the 400s
that that's an uphill battle for today
but
dark warrior just uh dropped in a twitch
sub putting us at 163.
david my girlfriend then i missed you
while you were gone glad to see you back
well i'm glad to be back
evan says got vaccinated in may
tested positive with two of my boys but
my wife and newborn who all share a room
with me tested negative covet is random
yeah that's that's weird
um i am going to get i'm being tested
tomorrow i i want to pass with flying
colors
but um the recommendation from the cdc
is you travel internationally you get
tested three to five days after getting
back i got a test within 72 hours of
flying back i'm doing what the cdc says
so tomorrow i will be getting a uh
actually i'm going to be getting two
tests tomorrow i'm going to just grab a
rapid test
like at cvs or walgreens
uh because my brother's flying in and
different things he's going to be tested
as well super strong test
and then monday i'm actually getting
like a like a lab
result test so i'll be getting tested
twice
um they i i'm hoping to test really
positively from the standpoint of
negative
heard someone call anti-vaxxers spread
necks and i laughed that's pretty good
actually
i don't trust the blue jacket guy keep
an eye on him blue jacket
blue do you mean the guy speaking or
who's wearing a blue jacket in the
background up here
man why is trump always an hour late
it's very strange
david sir any thoughts on the canadian
election not really i'm just getting
back and getting up to speed
my brother-in-law by double marriage
brian coldy dropping in a two dollar
super chat great to see coley coley help
me out with some uh technical issues
pretty recently
that related to multiple monitors and i
was able to get him on the phone and he
gave me everything i needed to know
kryptoneri says where do i put the promo
code 16 for 16. let me show you
you're going to be shocked by this
actually
look at this
you go to my website okay
you save even more when you go yearly
but you don't have to you could just do
monthly but let's let's imagine you
understand saving 18
okay you hit sign up
the field called coupon code that's
where the code goes
okay so i type in 16 for 16
and then 60
oh whoops i typed in 160. 16 for 16
becomes 16.
16 is the theme right i think people can
people can
sort of explain understand that
um let's check in again with with mo
brooks if that's even who this is
and i want you to make sure
that he can hear us and the sounds will
reverberate
and the way to do that
is to let him know as you were doing
earlier
how much we believe in the united states
of america and we can do that by
chanting usa so are you with me
usa usa
usa usa usa usa usa
god bless you for being here god bless
president trump god bless alabama and
god bless america
okay
[Applause]
all right uh the uh great magga mo
brooks taking the stage
uh what was i what's the last speaker
before we go into
all right so president scrumps will be
speaking soon people are accelerating
their membership sign ups i'm going to
try to thank everybody but this is a
it's it's crazy what's going on i do
want to say thanks to justine lampley
you know it's fascinating our audience
is like 70 male during the live streams
the memberships are like 70 percent
women it's wild i don't know what the
explanation is
um
justine lampley has just signed up
joe dub is a new member
thanks to philip stone for the
membership william shaffer okay now it's
now it's mostly mostly guys
uh thanks to philip de delore
and daniel mcdermott who has just signed
up
tanya jarvie is a new member so is brett
johnson and a very special thank you to
nathan hewer
all new members putting us at 171
for the day
propaganda is on screen i want to say
thanks to sean awashko
for signing up via twitch prime also
montana micah the pica has gifted a
subscription putting us at 173 and
remember that tonight only patreon
counts double
patreon.com davidpakmanshow every single
patreon will add two
which is crazy
let's see other super chats
hey david my mom and i love your show
you're the macgyver of opinion shows i
appreciate that assuming that it's a
compliment
what hair product do you use david i've
said this many times this is not a
sponsor i use one hair product and one
hair product only
it is um
fiber
from american crew that is the only hair
product i use not a sponsor
not a sponsor
just subscribe thank you for great
videos appreciate that thank you
rilo bailey says allegedly your show is
beautiful absolutely stupendous the
biggest most beautiful show the greatest
of all time many people are saying this
seriously it's going to be my bedtime
where is he at yeah it's going to be my
bedtime what does a membership include a
membership includes access to the daily
world famous and award-winning bonus
show now i'll be transparent there are
awards we give out but it is
award-winning
a commercial free audio feed of the show
a commercial free video feed of the show
members only updates from me as well as
invitation to invitations to occasional
member-only town halls
all right let's take a listen to the
propaganda video
it lives eats sleeps fights as a team
this individuality stuff's a bunch of
crap
this is just patton right that's what
this is is this from patton
well a saturday evening polo memberships
also include my only fans all access
pass and on that note look at all these
people signing up
stephen romanon
is a new member
adam muto just signed up brian french
john price
thomas asker
that's shocking that thomas signed up
eric carlson is a new member
jason wood just signed up
trishul jayaram
is a new member putting us at 181
um michael smith is a new member they're
almost coming in faster than i can uh
keep up
hi from montreal love montreal casamas
is one of my favorite restaurants
they're also pastaga
do you think trump supporters will get
sick of them for doing the same old
rallies with no content and crazy mike
lindell no
no
i don't think they will
they're bored during the rally anyway
pym tool says would you consider having
me on the show again certainly pim
anytime
blue coat red tie is the person oh okay
we can't see them now
what's the best way to become a credible
journalist in today's world for those
who can't afford college go intern at a
local paper if there's still one that's
kicking
where you live
thanks to kind af for the twitch sub
number 183 today
also thank you to about eight new
members here audrey harkenrider is a new
member
kathy hermanton has just signed up tim
sutton thanks tim chad mello is a new
member
carrie power has just signed up as has
mr seva
and also anthony berglund
putting us at 190 for the day also
thanks dennis poole for the twitch prime
subscription
we are moments from donald trump they
are playing a patent propaganda video
this has gone from delusional to
disturbing and it will soon be dystopian
and disgusting
and depraved
i i it's just it is what it is
the crowd enraptured by the propaganda
and you may thank god for it
thirty years from now when you're
sitting around your fireside
with your grandson on your knee
and he asked you
what did you do in the great world war
ii
this is all pretty pretty vile yeah
um who else do we have here i'm trying
not to miss people signing up here
and sending messages
will the flu klux klan still be holding
rallies this time next year
yes
sir what media do you use for
international news oh um mostly
newspapers actually i i primarily follow
argentinian news
um but a lot a lot of newspapers
um
[Music]
48 stars on the flag on stage
i object to the rally using the scene
from patton patton actually knew how to
lead for all his flaws trump couldn't
run a lemonade stand
i'm just a frenchie sir disappointed
with biden's handling of afghanistan do
you think trump's plan would have turned
out the same
yes i already uh addressed that and it
absolutely would have i believe that joe
biden getting us out of afghanistan is a
major accomplishment
he he just he did it
all right so we're going to hear from
trump soon let's see if i can thank
everybody who's signing up i want to say
thank you to kevin gouldy who just uh
pledged via patreon as well as nathan
hewer that's two but they count double
today meaning they count as four
i also want to say thanks let me see if
i can even get through this
whoa
let's see if i can get through it as
trump comes out samuel dooley just
signed up
uh wow
ron hamley is a new member
glennis bruin is a new member
brad duran has signed up i can't even
keep up sha-zhen ingram
mariama nance
nathan wenzlaf is a new member victor
lorenz
sherry townsend as well as lauren conrad
and jonathan crousen
there's no way i'm getting through all
these ashton lane is a new member
oh my god they're dumping it everywhere
liz labonte
danny johnson
carrie leonard
rita gillespie
dara johnston
joanna mangafest
i knew a guy named rich mengaphis
actually
laurel kamphausen
alan mcinnis
alexandra barnes
alison cross street these are coming in
faster than i can keep up guys
um peter reed
jerry merritt
okay hold on that was 21 right
putting us at 116.
uh okay let's see if i can get to the
last few betty morgan
bonnie steinbacher don michelle lopriano
madeline chapman wow the ladies are
really coming out today oh whoop i put
1100 wait
220 oh my god all right let's get let's
get this to trump here
okay it's still going so i can thank a
couple more people monica capito
really appreciate that number 221
ken eva
just signed up via twitch number 222
what a shame and a disgrace
that uh
this rally is happening
but uh
it is this is a big crowd i'll tell you
i'll keep the counter up to date guys
yeah this goes all the way back
i wish they'd show it because they just
don't do that there's a camera on it
right now all the way back i just looked
at it on television hello it's our
television we show it but they don't
show it you know why because they're
fake news right
[Applause]
hello alabama and i'm thrilled to be
back
in your incredible wonderful state that
we won by a record number we won this
state
alabama is actually a state he won they
don't tell you about
we did have a rigged election do we have
is terrible terrible and you look at
what's going on now you look at what's
going on now and the border but take a
look at afghanistan what's happening but
i'm with thousands of proud hard-working
china incredible american patriots with
your
help we're going to elect
our friend mo brooks
to the u.s senate let's hope not huh
we're going to fire nancy pelosi chuck
schumer joe biden and the radical
and we're going to make america great
again we have been making it so great
now they're biting into that but we're
not going to let that happen we can
never let that happen that's why you
know i had the idea all my ideas someday
they're going to tell me how to do
things he's an idea guy
piece did you like that general patton
that was his idea guys he came up with
that because we're getting a little
tired of the woke generals that we have
right it's a fall they move our military
out before they move our civilians and
before they move 83 billion dollars
worth of equipment let's move them out
and the taliban looks and they say
i can't believe it
this could only happen to us i can't
believe it the military left they go in
we have 45 000 people there americans
anywhere from i guess 15. they have no
idea how many that's even worse they say
it could be 10 oh it could also be 45
000 but it's a lot of people
and equipment like nobody has anywhere
in the world 83 billion dollars
one year ago this month in my nomination
acceptance speech which you remember a
lot of you were there i see a lot of you
that were there
i want the entire country of the
disastrous consequences of a biden
presidency i understood it a lot of you
understood none of it came to pass
interestingly but he did warn eliminate
america's borders in the middle of a
pandemic he did
i predicted that he would unleash a wave
of violent crime that would turn our
cities into
a nightmare of killing and bloodshed
you look at these democrat-run cities
chicago
l.a
big cities small cities
everyone run by a democrat new york they
don't prosecute people in new york only
republicans they prosecute they don't
prosecute murderers and killers they
prosecute murderers
it's
misconduct it's called prosecutorial
misconduct but i told you this was going
to be happening we stated it
loud and clear we said he would impose
crippling shutdowns and restrictions on
in-person schooling and that these
none of it's happened this would
nonetheless
fail
to stop
the virus he didn't stop the virus you
know they say oh he gets wonderful
marxists to get good marks he's done a
terrible job including on vaccinations
including on everything else
convalescent plasma is back
the virus is back i'm shaking hands with
everybody backstage i say well i don't
know this is a good thing
light and heat you'll read about it in
three or four days maybe hopefully not
but i said that that's not really even
funny embolden america's enemies and
that's what he's done and that the
radical democrat socialist agenda
which set our nation
on the road to economic ruin you look at
what's going on with inflation has
anyone noticed that your gasoline is now
at levels that you never thought you'd
see again
six months ago
so we had
we had
1.87 cents a gallon and we had a
thriving
industry
now all of my viewers already understand
what what's going on with gas prices we
didn't need the middle east
we didn't need the middle east
and now you have over five dollars in
many cases and it's going even here it's
going to be over five dollars very soon
and i saw the other day before this
whole thing with afghanistan started
because right right now nobody's talking
even about energy even about the
horrible border condition that they're
allowing millions of people to come into
our country people that we have no idea
but people aren't talking about they're
talking about the disaster
of afghanistan not only have
my predictions come 100 percent true but
it's wrong even worse than any of us
could have
imagined in our worst nightmare nobody
thought this kind of very wrong what
happened
biden has obliterated our border given
up our energy independence caused
soaring inflation he's already drenched
in sweat interestingly enough in
policies i mean you look at what's going
on it's crazy
and the senators that voted for this 1.2
trillion dollar bill of which they call
it infrastructure
but only 11
is infrastructure imagine booing
infrastructure are these people coming
from it's the road map
they call it the glide path it's the
road map
to the green new deal
conceived and dedicated by aoc a real
beauty
she's a real beauty
she knows more about the environment
i don't think she ever even took did she
ever take a course she wasn't a good
student did she ever take a course on
the environment
remember remember one first that you
have
12 years to live she said two years ago
that means you have right now you're
about nine and a half years
somehow
not worried about that but you are
worried about china
and russia and other places okay
all right we rebuilt our military
stronger bigger better than ever before
and now i see it being dissipated and
being given our military is being given
to the enemy
what
biden failed totally on the pandemic and
he's now overseeing the greatest foreign
policy humiliation in the history man of
the united states of america this is the
greatest humiliation
i've ever seen
biden's botched exit in afghanistan is
the most astonishing display what trump
means is good thing i wasn't able to do
it because the same damn thing would
have happened and getting us out of
afghanistan is a really great thing in
another situation like this
vietnam looks like a master class and
strategy compared to joe biden's
catastrophe and it didn't have to happen
all he had to do was leave the soldiers
there until everything's out our
citizens our weapons then you bomb the
hell out of the bases we have five bases
and you say bye bye
and you know trump would have done
better because of how well everything
went during his presidency every time he
did something sides and falling off
there'll never be anything like that
that's worse than the helicopters
you remember the helicopters taking off
the roofs this blows it away not even a
contest this will go down as one of the
great military defeats of all time and
it did not have to trump had to be told
that we can't really consider bombing
europe and that you also can't bomb
hurricanes and he wants us to think he
would have run this all well he had them
i dealt with abdul he was the leader oh
no i said abdul
anything happens we are going to reign
terror upon you
it will be a terrible thing
don't touch our american citizens don't
ever come to our country don't ever come
to our country
and you're going to continue fighting
your civil war i can't do that they've
been fighting it for hundreds of years
that's what they do is they fight and
they're good fighters but i had a good
relationship other than that the taliban
was formed in 1994.
now let's get down to business and we
had he said hundreds of years based
agreement and they didn't meet the first
two conditions and we hit him hard and
then they met him and then they had a
couple of other conditions that they
were ready to meet
and then we had a rigged election and we
had a new president and the new
president came into office and he
dropped to his knees and he said come on
in and take everything that we have
this is a disgraceful thing the most
embarrassing thing
that we now an interesting thing happens
right now we're about 10 minutes in
the crowd that's been there all day
they now start to realize
this is pretty boring and you start you
start to see the crowd tune out it
happens at every rally
they start lower lower energy
sometimes couples will start fighting
because they start looking at their
watch and they're like wait hold on do
you want to stay do i who's who are we
staying what's going on
he surrendered our air base he
surrendered our weapons he surrendered
our embassy
they spent a billion dollars building
this ridiculous embassy
and he abandoned our great american
citizens they're over right now they
have no idea
remember this the taliban's tough
and they don't respect our country and
they don't respect our president it's
not good
they're over there now and they don't
know what's going to happen our citizens
joe biden was
going on vacation
as afghanistan was going to hell trump
golfed the quarter of his presidency
and this is what you get when you have
weakness in the white house you can't
have weakness in the white house they
have to respect your president when i
was president
we only had strength remember the 59
shots we took at syria
59 missiles everything is he referring
to the runways he bombed after letting
russia know he would do it which were
back up and running within 24 hours is
that actually what he's referring to
right now chocolate cake at mar-a-lago
is wonderful it is okay okay
and when i said to him what we had just
done the missiles were launched he
looked at me and he goes
repeat
i didn't know he spoke english actually
he said repeat i said what did you just
say repeat
so he spoke a little more english than i
thought because he never said hello but
he said repeat
and
i said we just shot
59 missiles
ships
very far away
every one of them hit their target it
was an incredible display of talent and
weapons and the reason
the reason we did that is because we had
to because president obama and biden
drew the red line in the sand and said
don't cross it and they crossed it and
nothing happened
that's when russia got involved russia
went in they said oh nothing's going to
happen so russia got involved other
countries got involved that red line in
the sand from president obama that was
just absolutely it just didn't matter it
was just words it's a problem with a lot
of politicians actually but not mo
but it just
doesn't matter
when he said red line don't ever cross
it and they crossed it and nothing
happened but the 59 missiles were
an incredible display under my
administration everyone in the world
knew
not to mess around with america they
knew that
what he means is they knew there's no
point in talking to america anymore
because trump's president so like we'll
deal with climate change on our own
we'll figure out all this stuff on our
own as well as anybody
this would never have happened
if i was president our country was so
respected
everybody respected our country
china respected our country we took in
billions and billions of dollars in
taxes and tariffs sometimes he still
doesn't seem to realize the american
companies pay the tariffs the amer the
american companies pay the tariffs not
china
toward china change
as i personally told the taliban leader
if anyone ever double crossed the united
states of america it would be the last
thing that was during the negotiations
with the taliban he was negotiating with
terrorists
and you knew it better than anybody in
alabama knew it because one thing we won
alabama by a record we won south
carolina by a record and then they said
we lost georgia how the hell did that
happen
that doesn't happen
no we know how that happened we know how
it happened but under our leadership
america was respected again our people
did a great job i've been watching
mike pompeo secretary of state he did a
great job and he's going around
spreading the word and general kellogg
and others they've been great but they
understood this would never could never
happen could never happen
what is he talking about the military
first you moved the military last we had
total control militarily they would have
never come in we could have kept them
there for a long time but 21 years we
want to bring them home
but we want to bring them home with
dignity you know very soon
we're going to have september 11th and
you're going to have because of biden
the taliban flag flying over our embassy
flying over
our facilities
what so
that was not even a possibility that a
thing like that could happen we
decimated isis you remember that isis
we had a great great success when i took
over isis was all over the place and in
a short period of time
we killed its leader and founder al
baghdadi
we eliminated the senior ranks of al
qaeda and we terminated the world's top
terrorists in salamani
who killed a lot of american soldiers
and a lot of other people too
and they knew we weren't playing games
they understood that right from the
beginning
this proven record of america's strength
laid the groundwork to safely and
responsibly bring our troops back home
nobody was going to mess with us
and then this clown
they rigged the whole damn deal and he
got in office and now
now they're taking advantage of us and
remember this
this isn't stopping this is going to go
on for a long time
it's going to go on for a long time
this isn't going away this isn't like
a three-day hit going to go on for a
long time taliban great negotiators
tough fighters great negotiators
got 45 000 people
you got a lot of people also that
deserve to be helped
and they're not going to let them be
helped at all this is going to go on for
a long time this is a great stain
on the reputation of our country going
into the middle east
was one of the most
disastrous decisions that our country
has ever been involved with we've never
had a decision
in my opinion it was the worst decision
that we've
ever had it was quicksand quicksand
we should have gone in knocked the hell
out of it you know i met a general
his name was general kane i don't even
know maybe he's not even on my side who
the hell knows with these generals you
know i'm
when i get through with this guy millie
i mean how about millie remember oh
remember remember guys he supports the
troops this is the most pro-military guy
proudly walked to the church that the
protesters they tried to burn it down
but i walked to the church protesters
out there
and millie was walking with me
and the next day the radical left media
starts calling you shouldn't have walked
you shouldn't walk instead of saying i'm
proud to walk with my president not
because it's me because of the office
instead of saying that
he wanted to apologize for walking with
the president of the united states and i
said
and i said this guy doesn't have what it
takes and uh you're seeing that now
because the worst decisions i've ever
seen that's again why i put the patent i
just remembered it as i was coming over
here i said get that clip quickly
the people of alabama understand that do
you think that
let me ask you
do you think that general patton was
woke i don't think so what do you think
mike
mike was he woke i don't think so
i don't think he was too woke he was the
exact opposite you know what woke means
it means you're a loser everything woke
everything woke
it's true
everything woke turns to [ __ ] okay
that's true
now the crowd's into it
god loves it whoa he swore
they're cheering that he swore i mean
this is so humiliating the world sees
this and they just they just laugh it's
it's so embarrassing but they're they're
proud of it it's crazy that's what's
really crazy but socrates was supposed
to easily win but they went woke except
for a few of them i love those women
that stood up and they saluted our flag
there were some of them
but the one with the purple hair she
didn't play too well
she went well you can have her
and they didn't do too well
unfortunately we want them to do well
but they did but it's true about woke
you just take a look everything goes bad
elements of woke it's a shortcut to
losing everything you have they want to
get rid of our
great heroes and heroines they want to
get rid of our history our culture
we're not going to do it
we're not going to do it you know when
they were starting to rip down our
statues
and it started with people confederate
people generals some respected some not
but they're taking down our culture and
our heritage and then it started with
others and then it went to robert e lee
robert e lee was
a part of our history and then do you
guys have any idea why this woman is
facing
to to the left like why is she pointed
to the left like that anybody have any
idea name of george washington off
schools can you believe it
we're not going to let this stuff go on
the hardest thing i had to do
as president was signing letters to the
families of soldiers who were killed in
the middle east
often i called the parents very often
sometimes i went to dover
air force base that's where the
bodies of the soldiers would come in and
i'd see
them bringing a
young man young woman
in a coffin and i'd be with the parents
and i've told this story a couple of
times the parents would sometimes be
unbelievable that you would almost not
understand it was like
sir it's so great to meet you
and they'd always tell stories about
their child
so my sister you're on the cover of time
magazine again he was a quarterback
sir
he was a quarterback in college sir you
can't ask that question the nfl he was
really good he was so great and we're
waiting for the plane to come in
and sometimes they'd be talking about
their daughter lots of daughters were
killed
coming out of the middle east
my daughter was so beautiful sir she was
so incredible sir i think she's doing
very well and i'd say to the general and
the colonel that ran dover the great
people we have great mr president
how are you great generals the ones you
see on television are not the ones that
are great we have great generals and we
have great leaders and a great military
that what is he talking about it was
exhausting
but i say to the general and the colonel
that ran dover and they saw the bodies
coming in
many days of the week
i'd say general
it's amazing the parents
seem so fine they can handle it no they
can't go away my daughter perhaps i'd be
dating her no i just spent a half an
hour talking to them they're okay i mean
they understand
what happened they're okay no they're
not sir
when that plane pulls up sir that's big
you're doing very well unbelievable
powerful just like you saw three days
ago with the bodies dropping off the
sides mr president for people to leave
when you're hanging clean this is to a
plane bonkers this is completely crazy
you'll eventually have to let go how
desperate is that how sad and how
desperate
but when that cargo plane pulled up
and that door opened the general said
sir when that door opens
and you had
the most beautiful
young people carrying a coffin
or a number of coffins off of the plane
sir when that happens i don't even know
what i'm doing sir
so i was talking what was this point of
this story i don't even know what was
the point of the story i was amazed at
their strength
and 10 minutes later
i watched that same mother and that same
father
screaming
screaming running to the coffin as it
was being taken off breaking security
lines you couldn't see the way i'm
understanding this story is trump was
like
i was confused by people experiencing
human emotions which sometimes changed
from one moment to the next it's and
gives up
and it's a disgrace it's a disgrace to
our country
it's a disgrace
it's a disgrace to everybody the the
most
the most incredible the most incredible
people
but it was a it's a very it's a very
that was the saddest thing seeing that
dover you go to dover you go also to
walter reed
medical center incredible doctors i will
tell you this in most incredible doctors
and you see the kind of horrific
injuries
and you see the parents the wife the
husband standing and
looking over
the body of somebody that was just
absolutely shattered
in some cases no legs
in one case i'll never forget no legs
no arm and then the other arm and a half
and said to me sir i got lucky i was
able to save
so you can't ask that question and i'm
looking and i'm saying
we can never let this happen again it
was a terrible terrible thing that
happened it was such a horrific this guy
is a bigger idiot than i thought i mean
this is this is
what what is he talking about
the hell
[Applause]
thank you very much
thank you very much wasn't that entire
thing kind of insensitive like i don't i
mean it was an unintelligible but also
it seemed completely insensitive melded
in with the government but i've never
been a big fan of ghani i always said he
was a total crook i've said it for years
it turned out he was a
crook he was a crook and he left he fled
he fled with a lot of cash
what we've done how we got into that
mess is just amazing but we could have
gotten out with honor
and we should have gotten out with honor
and instead
we got out with the exact opposite of
honor when trump uses the word sir 30
times in a story it's probably a fake
story right this year somebody said oh
he's dealing with the taliban who the
hell else am i supposed to deal with
china deal with the people that ran or
the people that were highly paid you
know we paid the soldiers they were
among the highest paid soldiers in the
world
i remember a certain highly overrated
officer they're fighting for their lives
they're fighting for their country i
don't even know what i'm doing sir i
paid more than any soldier in the world
and when that payment stops they're gone
and that's exactly what happened
exactly what happened
but since my administration
began then this lady right here just
looked over and was like do you know
what he's talking about i don't know
what he's talking about other ladies
like no no i don't i have no idea
they're like okay so neither of us know
okay but in afghanistan it's over 18
months now 18
months
and you know why that is
not because the taliban aren't great
fighters because they are great fighters
all you have to do is ask yeah he's
praising the taliban way more than our
military that's for
and sure of
afghanistan it's now russia
much smaller version of what it was
because of afghanistan they went bust
spending so many years and so much money
and not winning
in afghanistan
but all of that money they spent
all of the lives they lost same thing
but all you have to do is ask
russia what do you think now i hear
they're going back in not so fast
everybody that's gone in
hasn't been so good and you know what we
have to go in and we should go in when
it's right
and we now may have to be forced to go
in because this person that
is running our country
made a horrific decision of taking all
of our powerful military out wait is he
saying now we should go into afghanistan
be forced but we may be forced to go in
and if you're not prepared to go in
you're never going to see those 45 000
people again throw them the hell out of
here if they don't think you're prepared
to go in you're never going to see again
whether it's 10 or 45
000 people you'll never see him again
all joe biden had to do
was follow our plan
it's like the border all he had to do
was go to the beach he didn't have to do
anything we had the tightest most secure
border we built almost 500 guys
rain knocked over the border wall today
rain knocked over the border wall today
and i would have had it much earlier but
i got sued by the democrats in congress
so much took two and a half years for me
to win rain and wind okay i'm sorry we
won all the lawsuits we built it at a
rapid pace raining about fetish helped
us great we set records records at the
border
all he had to do was go to the beach
same thing here all year
so if they don't follow it then we start
blasting them again they didn't want to
be blasted they were tired of being
blasted
they were tired you know with all due
respect that's a bunch of remarks he's
tough but you know what we're tougher he
just said it
but nobody would know it nobody would
know it when you look at what's
happening nobody would know it but we're
tougher i'd like to explain that to
abdul and to everybody else who are much
tougher please remember that
it's hard for them to understand that
now after watching this think of that
the soldiers have left i could just see
this
the leadership of the taliban standing
there abdul seems like an interesting
guy sir the soldiers have left sir
he goes what
the soldiers have left
and they've left all of their citizens
behind
and they've left 83 billion dollars
worth of equipment behind including
brand new apache helicopters
thousands of humvee vehicles with armor
guard
equipment that nobody has armor guard i
thought they were they had scotchgard
trump insists on scotchgard
so can you imagine these guys abdul and
his friends sitting there
that the united states soldiers usually
when he tells the story he says the
guy's name is muhammad now he's saying
the guy's name is abdul they walked in
and they took everything
it's crazy
it's crazy i've never seen i've never
seen anything so stupid
in my life somebody said
don't say it sir it's not good
i asked yesterday i was with a group of
people and there was a five-year-old
child
and i explained the situation to the
five-year-old child the child was like
an adult but smaller it was fascinating
what they're doing these days with
technology it was just like a small
person they actually do like it but
they'll never say it okay
but i s
[Music]
i asked the child
so what would you do after describing i
said how are you three feet tall how did
you do it and he said well sir i'm seven
i'm just not big yet all of that
incredible military equipment
or would you have the military go out
first
sir i'd leave the military in
sir
he said i'd leave the military and
get everything out first i said thank
you very much but they didn't want me to
tell that story they thought it was not
an appropriate story but it's true this
is a five-year-old kid unlike the other
stories this one is true inappropriate
but true
this is what we're stuck with
but when biden took office he foolishly
tore up
our really good plan again not a plan
it's biden did the plan do this we do
this we do this if you don't do these
things we're not going to do it and then
we start dropping bombs all over the
place and they say you know what we're
going to do it we've decided to do it
no we had a good understanding they
always hate it remember when i came in
obama said the worst problem we have is
north korea kim jong-un
i said what's the problem he said i
think you're going to go to war with
north korea
i said have you ever called him
no actually he called him 14 times and
was not responded to right trump doesn't
understand that north korea makes the
same promises all the time and so you
don't just give them a meeting and a
photo op trump didn't understand that he
thinks he figured something out he's
like i got him to meet with me they've
been trying to meet with american
presidents for 40 50 years it's the
point is you try to get preconditions
dear god
where'd the audio go
and
anyway it was very nasty and then all of
a sudden it became a love fest it became
great right and i went to north korea
went to south korea went across the line
we got along great there was no nuclear
catastrophe but you got to be careful
because he does not respect
joe biden and he does not respect any
longer america
but i said it's good to speak to people
i stopped the pipeline in russia i
stopped it nobody's ever been tougher to
russia but i got along great with
president putin we had a great
relationship
he said you're killing me with this
pipeline i said look
not right germany shouldn't have been
doing that you know
the european union takes tremendous
advantage of us
almost as bad economically it's total
free association he's all he's all over
the place
i say really how many chevrolets are in
beijing right now maybe none okay they
won't take our cars they won't take our
farm product they won't take anything
and i was hitting them hard and then the
china virus came and it was a terrible
period of time but we did the greatest
job and because the base was so strong
what we did was so strong our countries
donate plasma today please alone now
with all the inflation and everything
else
is such a strong foundation
that our country is doing great and
other countries are doing horribly
horrible horribly remember they used to
use
anything to hit us
when we got hit i closed it to china
closer to europe anything to hit us but
they'd say in south korea they're doing
so well and then i see the disinfectant
is there a way we can do something yeah
is doing so well india is being
decimated right now we did a great job
on that the ventilators the equipment
that we got the cupboards were all right
and everything that we did and then we
developed a vaccine three vaccines in
three months what a doofus nine months
and actually i'll tell you it was three
days less three days less than nine
months and it's great and you know what
i believe totally in your freedoms i do
you got to do what you have to do but
this is his code take the vaccines i did
it it's good take the vaccines but
you got no that's okay that's all right
they're booing him
wow they're booing trump saying get
vaccinated if it doesn't work you'll be
the first to know okay
i'll call up alabama i'll say hey you
know what but it is working
but uh you do have your freedoms you
have to keep you have to maintain that
you have to maintain that and you got to
get your kids back to school
[Applause]
and the mask issue is interesting
because
fauci said masks are bad and now dude he
said it in march of 2020. now he wants
you to wear 15 different masks at one
time i don't know
he also told me he was a great athlete
then i saw him throw out a pitch at the
baseball
i used to be a great athlete sir you did
really oh that's good then i watch him
with television
that's not an answer
notice trump threw out no first pitches
right sidney
issue here is not about whether to leave
afghanistan the issue is joe biden's
staggering incompetence and gross
negligence
he doesn't know where the hell he is you
think he's running the government he's
not running the government uh oh
creating the greatest
strategic humiliation that we've ever
seen as a country and it was
something that we
should have stopped and the general
should have done something they should
have done something they should have
talked to him and said look
commander-in-chief
but you just couldn't have done that if
he had
evacu if he just moved the people out he
should have done it and he should have
done it first
he had to have done it first you know
sometimes in life decisions are made and
when those decisions are made if they're
bad decisions you've got to get away
from them and you've got to get away
from them fast and if you don't get away
from them you're not going to have a
country anymore you know i said about
elections
if we don't have great elections if we
don't have borders if we don't have the
things that are being taken away from us
we're not going to have a country
anymore and certainly we're not going to
have a respected country anymore
with me in office the taliban would not
have ever dreamt
of capturing our airfield or hey guys
now this woman's facing the opposite way
isn't there something kind of strange
going on there i really don't get what
is what's going on she's facing away now
from the stage we made them
there would have been no emergency
embassy evacuation and no taking down of
our flag they took down our flag
because we would have established clear
lines that the taliban would have never
dared to cross
the problem with biden is that our
enemies
are not afraid of him they don't respect
him our adversaries she's looking for
the exit okay no longer trust him they
can't trust him any longer
remember he went back and he went to
europe
and they didn't know what the hell was
going on
and he said we're back we're back in
other words we're back now you can
continue to take advantage of us
because europe took advantage of us
with nato like nobody ever you know i
got i got europe to pay
430 billion dollars toward nato they
would have never paid for 15 18 years it
was like this the payment
and we're protecting them and some of
them were totally delinquent they didn't
pay
and i said you got to pay they said sir
what would happen if we didn't pay would
you protect us i said if you didn't pay
i would not recommend protecting you and
it was amazing how fast that money came
in right that money came in that money
came in fast 430 started off with 130
billion billion not million billion
and then 430 billion came in very
quickly we did a lot of good things with
south korea
i said we protect you for nothing you've
got to pay
you're a rich country you make the boats
you make all our television sets which
you took from us thank you very much you
make so many cars for us
you got to pay and they agreed and they
paid
billions of dollars at my request it
wasn't that easy it took a little while
like about two days right
they agreed to pay billions of dollars
trump needs to convince us that it was
hard but easy for him but still
difficult next year we're left to the
election
but you're gonna have to pay at least
five billion dollars no no no we will
not pay
i said yes you will pay we have 32 000
soldiers in south korea
he said no no no president nice man good
man but he said no you know which he
should say why should he when he's you
know suckering us for so many years
so he said no no i said you're gonna
have to pay five billion but then the
election result turned out different
than what it should have
different from the real result and
i just heard they made a deal with south
korea to pay a cost of living adjustment
you know that is nothing when the money
i raised
it's like nothing
and that's the source crowd's checked
out now another country i'm sure that
was extremely happy with the results but
i did a great job in protecting them i
think i've saved them from kim jong-un
so i don't think they uh
a lot of people from south korea come up
to me and say thank you very much sir i
really i think i saved them from kim
jong-un because of the relationship i
can stand by
god's like okay all right
president and look he makes jimmy carter
look
great right
look at that man with that jacket i love
you man you've how many rallies have you
come to how what number is this
much more than that he's all
much more throw them they have some
women where are they here tonight north
carolina where are they where are they
we have some women
they've been to 96 i didn't even know we
did 96.
said how many sir we're up to about 96 i
said i didn't know we did that many
but you know look this is a very
unpleasant subject
but still
is this the greatest place to be in the
world
right
unpleasant to talk about it
but sometimes you have to think and talk
about unpleasant things
but not only is it biden and the
embarrassment to the united states
abroad his radicalism and extremism is
currently destroying our nation
right here at home
and nobody understands that better than
alabama
obama
remember when biden
used to go and say like
he's in iowa
and it's a it's great to be in idaho sir
you're in iowa he would do this all the
time
he was in new hampshire
it's great to be in maine today sir
you're in new hampshire
the worst was when he was in
he was in new york
and he said it's great to be in florida
there were no palm trees
great to be in florida who do that all
the time are any of these things true
i've never done it with all the speeches
i've made i was just saying because i
said alabama but i know exactly i didn't
have to think about it it's called
alabama i love alabama i've always loved
alabama
so there's a storm cell that's pretty
bad that seems to be somewhere in the in
the range of 15 to 20 minutes from
coleman alabama i'm really hoping
that the weather just goes absolutely
nuts and we see trump run off stage or
do something something bizarre if that
ever happened
it's a disaster you might as well just
walk off the stage
because you could be winston churchill
great speaker
you could be winston churchill the great
winston church he'll make an incredible
rest of the speech and it's a disaster
the only difference is
if you make a speech
if he does it which he does all the time
different forms the press doesn't cover
it he's the only guy that didn't get
covered falling walking up the stairs to
everything
the press didn't cover it other than a
couple internet covered it i guess right
it was sort of like on the news all day
that day actually um
yeah
down goes frasier remember that down
he kept going down and up down and up i
said what the hell's going on here's
what watching that what going on with
our president
and it wasn't on one nightly newscast
i think i might have been on i did the
ramp the long slippery ramp i said
general
it was pouring out pouring i said
general this is a bad deal here i got
leather shoes on the bottom
and i'm going to fall i'm not going to
let them i'm not so i walk down tiny
little steps
what's wrong with the president the
biggest story
i was so proud when i got down i didn't
fall i said general i don't want to grab
you but i may have to grab your big
strong general commandant of west point
i made you know i made my best speech at
west point that day oh yeah but then it
was pouring it was great and when i went
down the ramp and it was pure it wasn't
you know normally they have like some
little grooves nothing it was like an
ice cave totally slick yeah it was a
trap he needed a guy to hold his hand
it's okay the general this is not a good
situation that sucker looks slippery as
hell and i'm not going to allow them
to take me falling remember gerald ford
fell that was not a good time
some of the bad things happened to
presidents not a good time you can't do
that you can't let that happen so what
happened is they made that a big story i
was so proud of myself i made my best
speech and nobody talked about that
speech someday hopefully they'll go back
and get the speech i made at the
graduation of west point two years ago
i'd love you to hear that speech i
called up the first lady i said first
lady i just made a great speech and she
said sir you're on television for the
way you went down a ramp
it's all they talked about but with him
falling down the stairs three times he
was down no he's up no he's down again
oh my god
no he's up he's down again he's down for
three times you know if that were a
fight
they'd stop it right
if that were a fight they would have
stopped it mike
in a matter of mere months biden has
thrown our southern border
wide open when i left office we
handed the new administration the most
secure border in u.s history and they
turned it into the greatest
border disaster in american history
probably anywhere in the world you know
they're emptying their prisons out into
our country oh yeah just talking about
guatemala honduras el salvador mexico
i'm talking about middle eastern
countries uh-oh yemen people are coming
in from yemen
our country will
will really be in trouble there's no
evidence that people are coming in from
yemen through the southern border we
ended
the ridiculous catch and release you
catch somebody
you find out they're a criminal and you
release them immediately into our
country
we ended asylum fraud we deported record
numbers of criminal aliens we negotiated
historic agreements with mexico and
central america to stop illegal
immigration
and we built all of that wall that i
just talked about
but we had a stay in mexico policy you
can't come into our country i'm sorry
stay in mexico
biden ended it he ended it but you know
what happened yesterday we won in court
and a very wise judge said
we're allowed to have stay in mexico
thank you judge
thank you judge crowd has no idea what
he's talking about thank you very much
[Music]
i mean they used to stay in the united
states and then you'd never find them
again you say and you know some of these
people are
seriously tough criminals
i achieved a 90 reduction in illegal
border crossings think of that 90 it was
going to go much higher
and brought illegal immigration to a
virtual halt it was the lowest levels
ever recorded
and you could come into our country but
you had to come in legally finally we
did it but we had to win a lot of court
cases
many of those court cases for people in
the audience who are bored and there
seem to be a lot of you we could be like
10 to 15 minutes from an insane
thunderstorm wreaking havoc on this
event and i'm sort of in my mind looking
forward to that it might be more
interesting and you will be immediately
sent back home where you belong
and when people heard that and they hear
it they're genius it's genius when
people heard that and then they saw the
results because it was at games it was
happening they never came they stopped
remember at the beginning with the
caravans
we ended the caravans but now the
caravans are back at a level that
nobody's ever seen how convenient
stronger more powerful
to disgrace now the radical left
democrats have surrendered our
sovereignty to the coyotes and drug
cartels child smugglers
humans coyotes and dingoes both are now
in control
biden stopped wall construction
instituted nationwide catch and release
wanted it back
and invited the entire world to make a
mad dash for the usa when he said come
you're welcome
i don't know if he knew i does he do
people think this is a good thing what
happened they're destroying our country
they're destroying last month alone
border patrol
who we love
apprehended a mind-boggling 210 000
illegal border crosses you can multiply
that times six seven
eight or nine
of the people that come in without
getting caught they say you can use
numbers like that
record numbers are getting away and
historic numbers are coming from outside
mexico and central america from every
corner all over the world a lot of them
coming in from the middle east at this
rate millions of illegal aliens will
cross our border just this year alone
millions millions
many of them
so bored
hardened criminals murderers
again think of this just think of the
statement
they are emptying their jails
into the united states think of that
a lot of people don't know what that
means
we're looking versus they are the
toughest jails they're emptying them
into the united states
this massive overcrowding on our border
is a super spreader disaster that will
bring
new variants into our nation and
honestly far worse than variants
far worse
ms-13 is being replenished to levels
never seen before
i brought ms-13 through ice and border
patrol out by the
thousands we were going into towns in
long island and these were brave
warriors like law enforcement as we have
so much respect and they'd go right into
what they call a nest
of a lot of these gang members
all these guys that i know my friends in
the first row i know every one of them
very well
not one of them would do this job and if
they did they'd be knocked out in about
two seconds
they wouldn't do it well they wouldn't
want to do it ice is these are brilliant
great tough strong
but more important than anything
patriotic people
they would go into these towns and they
would get these hardened criminals that
are loaded up with weapons and they
would get them the hell out of them
everybody's looking at weather reports
now i'm seeing 83 rain right now in
coleman alabama so quite literally any
second we could get a downpour
shut down interior enforcement and
turned our nation into a giant sanctuary
for dangerous criminals we have
criminals coming in this country
nobody knows what how bad it's going to
be watch that's another trump prediction
in the republican party we believe our
country should be a sanctuary for law
abiding americans not for criminal
aliens
i'm rooting for the storm we found the
gang members drug dealers and various
ms-13 killers and we kick whirly i mean
i i mean quickly we knock them out so
fast nobody could believe it thousands
thousands a year
and we quickly deported them
or we put them behind bars where they
belong sometimes they were so evil so
vicious we didn't want to take a chance
on bringing them back
to their countries and their countries
didn't want them you know you know that
story i've told that story
when i came in
we'd catch these people and border
patrol ice i'd meet with the top people
they're incredible people they'd say sir
they won't take the people i said what
do you mean they won't take them they
don't want them back they don't want
the gang members back they don't want
the killers back they won't take them
back
when we fly in with an airplane they put
planes on the runway so we can't land we
have to come back the buses they stop
they won't take them back sir none of
the three major countries that we're
talking about
honduras guatemala el salvador they
won't take them back sir
i say really do we give them any money
every year this is sure
i learned exactly what it was but early
on you know hadn't done it too long
right
do we get many money yes sir how much
about 500 million dollars a year he's
better than i got the money right
so i said good stop payment immediately
no more money going to these countries
no more more
no more money going to these countries
i immediately stopped all of this 500
million a little more than that
500 million going to the three countries
and a day went by and i got a call from
all three of the heads of those
countries who i knew and
and know and respect they're smart
they're very streetwise people okay very
smart and very very streetwise mr
president you stopped
many millions of dollars from coming
into honduras and guatemala
and el salvador you stopped it from
coming in mr president
is there something we did wrong yes
you're not taking back people that came
into our country illegally you will not
take them back oh there must be some
understanding sir
we would love to have them back
i said congratulations
we'll be sending lots of planes your way
and we did we got them all back
[Music]
anybody know what he's talking
delayed that about
in a long time
we still didn't make the payment we
waited a long time but they took them
all back
and then the other day i heard
that biden wants to give those countries
four
billion
dollars with all due respect that's a
bunch of malarkey
because he thinks that they're going to
spend the money on economic development
no it's going to go economic development
into their bank accounts in switzerland
okay that's the economic development
we're talking about trump would now give
them 4 billion
they're working on the paperwork right
now
the money's going to be stolen it's
going to be given to the cartels it's
going to be given to the traffickers
it's going to be kept by politicians
see we only have honest politicians in
our country
right
like mo
that's true
okay
we understand and we've understood very
much in
america first that immigration security
is national security
and that's why we instituted the travel
ban remember the travel ban i took such
heat
where i was able to get people that came
into our country from very tough
countries china very very tough
countries and i was able to stop them
from coming to our country china because
we didn't want to have our stores blown
in china all the time we didn't want to
have buildings set on fire and death and
destruction
so we didn't we lost at the lower court
we lost at the second court and then we
won at the united states supreme court
and to show you how dishonest the press
is recently they wrote about it they
said he lost in court the crowd's
increasingly distracted by something in
the background but then i won
i said you didn't you didn't say i won
well you did lose you know in other
words technically they're right i lost
their court but i work nickly then we
have a travel ban
and without that travel ban you would
have some really bad bad people in here
from places in the world that are evil
and it was a great thing i took a lot of
heat over that travel ban people said
that's not nice they all like to call it
a muslim ban it wasn't a muslim muslim
ban from a lot of different countries
that are bad and they send bad people to
us it's not racist
and we didn't have to accept that
so it was a great success but they try
and make it look like it wasn't very
nice we dramatically reduced
refugee admissions and kept radical
islamic terrorists
the hell out of our country oh where's
this lady going
one of the first acts that biden did
after mitch mcconnell said we must get
back to work we have to get our country
going we have to approve him as the
president
even though the evidence was staggering
you'll see the evidence starting to come
out it's already come out far beyond
what we need by the way far far far
beyond what we need we have to get back
to our country and running our country
mitch mcconnell and the first thing that
biden did was sign 17 of the worst
executive orders in the history of our
country
and one of them biden revoked that
beautiful wonderful
are people leaving what's going on here
and a surged refugee resettlement
from the most dangerous countries in the
world the most dangerous terrorists in
the world they come into our country now
with no problem come on in
it's love to love to have you
this is a sick culture and our country
is a disaster and it's going to die
before your very eyes if this
craziness isn't stopped in so many ways
you know
the afghanistan thing is so simple to
understand because you know it's really
when people watch that people that
weren't even
into watching political things on the
news
but when people
watch this they understood it
immediately about the military don't
take them out leave it till last sort of
like the captain of a ship
let's jump off first before the
passengers i'm getting the hell out of
here
right that's what it is the captain is
supposed to wait and watch i'm getting
reports that were eight minutes from a
downpour when you have dishonest and
rigged elections this is what happens
this is what you get our nation
is being destroyed from within by people
who have no right to destroy it
no right they have no right to destroy
it
as everyone here understands the
2020 election that presidential election
which was such a great day at 10 o'clock
it was over
pennsylvania trump is winning by a lot
arizona trump is winning by a lot we
don't even talk about alabama that there
was nothing they could do with this one
there was nothing
okay
[Applause]
and it'll go down you're going to see
things happening it'll go down as the
most corrupt election in american
history and almost probably in any
history yeah the evidence of the fraud
is monumental i need 11 more is coming
out
just recently wisconsin election
officials
admitted they removed more than 200
000 voters by the way that's
10 times more than i need to win they
call them sometimes more
200 000
from the voter rolls and they did it
unfortunately
why didn't they move them before the
election they removed them after the
election oh thank you very much
i appreciate it they removed these
names after the election
was over approximately 20 times more
than we needed
earlier this month it was revealed that
in georgia ballots were rejected by
machines and illegally altered by hand
to remove marks for trump and instead
cast votes for joe biden you'll see that
coming out you're going to see many of
them could only take another few years
it'll come out you had
a little thing little problem more votes
than voters a little problem
that's a lie detroit it's like we've
debunked all these things
many more votes than their voters oh
that doesn't sound so good does it huh
and i needed just a little bit just a
little bit didn't eat all didn't need
much of it
for example in nevada it was recently
discovered that 15
out of the state's 17 counties had more
votes than voters
no it was not run by democrats yeah i
wonder how that happened
in arizona 11 000 individuals
are now listed as having voted
who were not even on the rolls the day
after the election they weren't listed
on the rolls
none of the
margins in the state
remember this the margin was
less than 11 000 substantially
so that was much more than we needed
that was just one of many categories the
arizona auditors right i need 11 000
votes give me a break stating
that county election workers abolish
signature matching entirely okay well
that sounds reasonable no signature in
other words whose signature is it we're
not allowed to match oh that's great
maricopa county has refused to comply
with an official subpoena to provide
images of the envelopes which were
this would prove whether they indeed
counted ballots with no signatures at
all many of the ballots weren't signed
they were just thrown in there
finally a recent trend analysis of all
50 states based on population growth
voter history and voter race this guy's
rubbing his eyes by one of the most
respected people in that industry
somebody
so respected military person captain
seth keshel
found over 8 million excess biden votes
in other words
he had 8 million more votes than he's
supposed to have
and his estimate is conservative he
considered it very conservative and i
believe he said he didn't even go to the
machines this is without even looking at
the machines this is without any
evidence at all i'm not the one trying
to undermine american democracy i am the
one trying he's like this guy without
actually looking at anything substantive
thinks biden got eight million too many
votes oh okay well well
the numbers speak for themselves we got
12 million more votes
than in 2016.
i was told
by the best pollsters in the world
real policies john mclaughlin posters
that are used by certain of the fake
news media
if i got one million more votes i
couldn't lose i got 12 million more
votes
and we lost you know obama the second
time got millions fewer votes and it
just happened to the audio
but i was sold
by the most talented pulsers and polling
his talent polling works but not when
it's
fraudulent polling
get one million votes sir you cannot
lose it'll be an easy early evening we
got 12 million votes and they said we
lost and we didn't
we won 18 out of 19 bellwether counties
which is
unprecedented we flipped 15 house seats
remember we were going to lose 25 to 35
house seats instead of losing 25 or 35
we won 15. it was a big evening and you
know why because they came in on our
coattails that's what happened the
congressman will tell you that and women
they will tell you that
and did not lose a single republican
incumbent in congress think of that
for the first time congressman we never
think of that
this was in decades and decades we
didn't lose one seat you know why
i hate to say it because of me
it's because of me
and despite the
pandemic 56
this was a record of americans this is
during the pandemic
believe that they were better off in
2020 than they were in 2016 when i
assumed though sure sure 56 is a record
and we had a pandemic going
a majority of americans 55
want audits of the votes they want
audits
do they even know what it means the
forensic orders they don't want the
they don't want the
[ __ ] audits
and 88 percent
of the
americans the sirens of our citizens of
our great people are demanding voter id
if it downpoured right now it would just
be the best someone who has fought
harder than anyone else in congress to
expose the
election fraud he is really a fighter
and to defend the integrity of our
elections
and i have to say it i just can't
imagine him losing he's got courage he's
an honest guy
he's an honest guy and that gives him
the courage your next u.s senator from
alabama mo brooks thank you
i know most spoke but come up and say
just a quick word though
[Music]
he's doing very poorly in the polls he's
only up at about 90 percent
come on mo
thank you mr president
and future president of the united
states of america
oh dear
i'm pleased to announce the second
coming of president donald j trump oh
god
go get
him thank you mom
so mo is a fearless warrior for your
sacrifice jesus rhetoric and so many
other things he's going to be an
incredible senator and we're proud of
him
and we're proud of
my cherish your cherished but my
cherished alabama i feel like
i don't know the relationship
the relationship has been so strong
right at the beginning you know before i
knew anything i just knew we had a thing
called common sense together thank you
quite a crowd huh
[Applause]
thank you everybody thank you i love you
too
but it is true you know early on
i said how are we doing in alabama
sir you're up about 45 points this was
before i knew any idea how many times
will he tell this story that sounds good
we're up at numbers that nobody's ever
seen before we've never gone down now
we're up higher than we ever were
and you also have somebody that is
unbelievable
unbelievable
he happens to be now a senator he was an
unbelievable football coach tommy
tuberville tommy
stand up tommy
where's tommy
where's tommy i love tommy where the
hell is he
where is he
he's here
a hell of a crowd i want to tell you
this crowd
goes so far back see the cameras
we shouldn't give that to the media
because all they do is they block the
viewer they don't say the truth anyway
this crowd see what this is goes
hundreds of yards behind those cameras
look at that man
tommy is i'd love to see tommy i love
tommy he's doing a great job i said you
know tommy you uh
you're running for senate and he did a
good job he was a natural and he was a
rah-rah coach but he was a great coach i
asked urban myers
how good a coach was tommy tuberville he
said he beat me twice he's the only one
that beat me twice
but i said tommy you beat alabama six
times
i said
i said
i said how can you possibly expect the
people of
alabama
to vote for you he said sir because i
gave them a coach named saban
because of me
i said
i said tommy that's the coolest answer
i've ever heard
and you voted him in and he's been a
great senator he's been phenomenal thank
you very much thank you tommy thank you
very much
incredible guy incredible guy
and he's got that look of a senator
doesn't he right not that looks matter
i always say looks don't matter you know
nowadays looks don't matter but he's
still got the look of a senator
he's doing a great job lieutenant
governor will
ainsworth will
thank you will great job nice meeting
you backstage alabama attorney general
steve
marshall steve
thank you steve thank you thank you very
much
representatives jerry carl
barrymore gary palmer
robert where's robert robert
robert aderholt he's been another one
all right let's
let's take some calls now if people want
while this continues and we'll keep an
eye out on the rain i mean it's like you
know what he's saying is just nonsense
it's the normal nonsense so i promise to
take a few calls let me take them now
via discord davidpakman.com discord in
the waiting lobby um i'll give a few
minutes for people to jump in there and
then we'll keep an eye on this as well
she's great
she is great she's a warrior
she's a warrior everything i said about
georgia is true audrey right yeah
a great gentleman chief justice of
alabama supreme court tom parker tom
thank you very much
thank you tom a lot of power
all right let's hear from a couple
people let's check in with uh for
example denver from seattle uh everybody
get right to your points please because
we are in the middle of a rally denver
what's going on
hey david can you hear me yes i can
hey thanks love the show uh good to talk
to you i was just wondering quick
question do you know what in the latest
uh possible time
that uh trump would need to officially
announce that he's running instead of
doing these little teases are as far as
from the standpoint of campaign finance
law oh he could wait a very very long
time there's no rush at all i mean at at
least a year after 2022 i would guess
okay that's pretty much all i have for
you all right thanks denver there's
denver from seattle we're standing by
for rain and different things here with
trump trump's still going and going
um oh i don't know how about preston
from maryland what's going on
hello
hello
yeah um
i wasn't expecting to get on i was just
watching your stream i just wanted to
say that uh
the the patent that
that video clip from pat and that was
really creepy it was bizarre it was it
was really reminiscent of just like very
standard pro war propaganda type stuff
yeah yeah like it was like first grade
like very basic stuff it's insane that
it works on folks i mean it's just it's
wild it's really wild
yeah thank you
all right thank you very much this
people are getting right to their points
i'm i'm taken aback by it because it's
so rare
um let's try
uh trey from missouri you're on the air
can you hear me yes i can
so my question was more about sort of
the the the
coming of of the progressive movement
post ohio primary yeah i think that one
of the issues the progressive movement
has is that well we we want to push for
all these policies
uh we have a hard time sort of taking
wins when we can get them and building
on those wins we kind of try to shoot
for the stars and and when we don't get
them sometimes you know we're very quick
to to blame
others instead of maybe looking within
is that something that you see and if
you do see that um is that a possibility
can that hold back the progressive
movement from actually achieving not
only legislative victories but
ultimately electoral victories as well
that might apply in some cases i mean
for me the nina turner thing was just
the if you look on twitter and read it
it seems like there's way more
enthusiasm for her than there really is
and
more people are sort of
right now in the democratic party
uh there's a lot of people that are sort
of in the bidenism type camp that's what
it meant to me it wasn't about shooting
for the stars and falling short but that
could be the case in some races
all right i just i just had that
question because it just seems like
progressives are very much it's either
we win or we don't and there's kind of
no you know we can build on this but but
thank you anyway thanks for taking the
call man my pleasure great to hear from
you for people who were wondering donald
trump has been speaking about 75 minutes
already we're just taking a few calls um
in in the meantime because it's gotten
it's gotten really bad let's just see
what he's talking about
we never took in 10 cents from china so
he's back on chinese tariffs which he
misunderstands let's go next to chase
from florida you're on the air
hello can you hear me yes i can
alright it's nice to meet you david long
time listener first time caller
um
one of the questions that i've been kind
of
uh thinking about i was listening to the
majority report and they had someone on
there that was talking about how
it's like the end of being able to
like work with republicans like how when
the pandemic hit like it wasn't a matter
of um okay we can recognize the pandemic
as a problem how do we solve it it's
like the question of is the pandemic
even a problem and that's like a huge
split so
how do you how do you think we go from
this is there a way to like bring people
back to the common ground or is this
just kind of the end of maybe like the
end of history
it listen it's not the end i don't i
think we will only know the end of
history after the fact and we may not be
here to actually know it so that's
that's complicated but um no i don't
know how we get out of it it certainly
could be this bad for a while because
this is um i mean you know as i said
before there isn't even agreement as
agreement anymore as to what is a fact
not what the facts are but what count as
facts and i i have no clue how we get
back from it it's crazy i mean just
looking at this crowd in alabama it's
it's just unbelievable
yeah true
well thanks for taking my call my
pleasure thank you uh
appreciate people getting right to their
questions today let's go to alex from
los angeles next
hey david can hear me i can hear you
fine
all right awesome um
so my question is
i'm wondering your thoughts on i feel
like i've seen a lot of people on the
left i have friends like this i think
somebody like joe rogan and somebody
like bill maher would fall in this
category where
they
they become so anti-woke that it becomes
basically their main talking point
they're constantly talking about the
problems with wokism
um
and they perceive it to be this really
big kind of issue i'd say sam harris
kind of has a similar kind of take on
this
and they they basically i think get
sucked into a lot of right wing talking
points and i feel like it is almost a
pipeline
from the left to the right and i don't
know i just want to see your thoughts on
that yeah i haven't watched much of any
of the three of them but the mechanism
you're talking about rings true for a
while you know the whole intellectual
dark web it was all about like this is a
group we're about free speech and oh
there's people on the left and there's
people on the right but it was
effectively a pipeline to the right in
practice it doesn't mean there weren't
leftists there like brett weinstein or
you know whatever else but um yeah i
mean it be it became a de facto pipeline
that that mechanism exists
yeah do you feel like it's
you know hurting the left on a big scale
or do you do you see it as not being
no i don't i don't think so in the same
way that the
the online world made it seem during the
primary
like bernie was more popular in the
democratic party than he was i think the
same thing applies with this online
stuff on anti-woke and and so on where
it seems bigger than it really is for
just the average americans
okay yeah yeah cool well thank you for
answering my question my pleasure thank
you for the call
uh very good calls today let's listen
back into the rally
if you took a barrel of oil they gave
you 37 i told my people why didn't you
do that
it's still very very dumb let's hear
from a few more people i promise to do
it and when i promise to do it i do it
let's check in with ryan from
newfoundland
ryan from newfoundland you're on the air
oh no
is this our first drop
oh
i disconnected it at the very last
second all right let's try ryan from
portsmouth instead we'll keep going with
ryan
hey david how you doing i'm doing well
good i had a completely unrelated
question to all of this um it's actually
about education um i'm a math professor
um what are your impressions on recent
high school graduates getting ready for
the workforce or entering college given
the last year with covid distance
learning virtual learning etc i i have
no special knowledge of that that would
really be a question for people like you
who have been in the schools i mean i
think you know anecdotally we hear it's
been really tough
um we hear
not just from right wingers that it
would certainly be better to be back on
a full in-person schedule aside from
whether it makes sense from the
standpoint of the pandemic but i don't i
mean it seems to me that it's a
challenge and virtual learning is not
the best for a lot of people but i don't
have any special insight
okay i think like one of my big issues
is the possibility that
students or other people are not going
to have like the social skills they get
in that last year of high school yeah um
they're going to have trouble with just
in general with like interviews gonna
have trouble with a lot of different
things so i just wondering you know if
you had any opinions on that i i would
assume that you're right that that that
sounds very plausible to me
all right thanks a bunch my pleasure
great to hear from you let's listen into
the rally a little bit biggest tax
increase in history if they're allowed
to do what they are trying to do allow
the government to try taxing america
drivers by the mile they want to tax you
by the mile
and grant about so still ranting in a
way that is not
very sensible let's go to julie from
burlingame california next
julie you're on the air in california
and julie if you unmute we would be able
to speak to you
all right
no julie that's too bad
let's try chris from maine chris you're
on the air
hmm
chris from maine you're on the air
can you hear me
yes i can
sorry i had pushed a talk on and i
didn't realize that um
so
if there was an actual mechanism which
there isn't
what would what do you think the closest
thing would
be coming uh for trump to become
president even though there's not a real
mechanism you mean to be reinstated
yeah there there's i can't think of
there just isn't there's no mecca it
would be for him to run and win in 2024.
that's it okay okay and uh one more
thing um
i'm happy to hear that your girlfriend
uh is um
positive from the standpoint of negative
for covin exactly things came out very
positively on covid tests from the
standpoint of negative i appreciate that
yup thank you okay very good
um so a lot going on as people can tell
as we are standing by maybe for for rain
i'm told it really could be any second
but there may be no rain at all let's go
to jamie from texas jamie you're on the
air
hello david
hello can you hear me yes i can
um
i had a question on just
republicans missing the point on pop
culture like there was a rally where
they were playing green day
um i keep seeing
uh
bumper stickers where it's the thin blue
line over a punisher skull and it's like
these things just
don't mix and i was wondering why they
keep popping up in on the right and if
they're like missing the point or if
they're doing this to own the libs it's
i just think they don't that you're
you're saying because they're using all
sorts of things that are sort of like
not really right-wing things
yeah because like the punisher operates
outside of the law in the comics and yet
they're using it to symbolize strength
in law enforcement green day is a punk
band but they're playing it at trump
rally yeah they're also all left-wing
you know
the the guys from green day i mean
yes also like um i think they're just
dumb i think they're just dumb that's it
i don't think there's much else to it
they just have no idea what these things
represent
they just legitimately missed the point
and you don't understand what these
lyrics or people symbolize it's like
reagan using sprint springsteen's born
in the usa when it was an anti-war song
and and was about everything reagan was
not for
okay uh thank you that that's everything
from me all right thanks very much i'm
told the rain is starting let's tune in
together they don't have mitt romney and
these guys that
go off on their own they don't have
people like that
little ben sass he said nothing they
don't have people like this all right
let's focus in here and take a break
from the calls as the rain seems to be
getting going for trying to destroy our
country
with the republican congress we will
fight for more jobs for american
families fair trade for american workers
and we've done more on trade deals than
any other administration in the history
of our country
including the china deal which i don't
even talk about anymore because of covet
but the china deal has made our farmers
rich our farmers and manufacturers have
never done better and more american
factories forging more products stamped
with that very beautiful phrase made in
the usa
oh is he rushing to the conclusion
because of the rain
so in conclusion our movement is up
against some of the most sinister forces
and entrenched interests that anyone can
even imagine
but no matter how big our
way of life no matter how big our
country or how powerful
they may seem
you must never forget this nation does
not belong to them
this nation belongs to you
this is your home
this is your heritage and our
magnificent american liberty is your god
given hey guys how great is this super
chat david so glad you're back very
powerful stream today left out loud
multiple times hope you're able to apply
this five dollars to a three million
dollar property yeah i will do it via a
trust of course
corrupt tyrants left-wing bullies or
socialist
bureaucrats in washington d.c
a place that i got to know very very
well
we are descended
from the heroes and the patriots the
pioneers and the legends who tamed the
great wilderness who settled this vast
continent and who laid down the
railroads
raised up the skyscrapers
and poured out their blood sweat and
tears to build this country into the
greatest nation in the history of the
world and we are not going to let it be
taken away
from us under any circumstances
our ancestors
crushed
fascism
beneath the weight of
american tanks they toppled communism by
the strength
of american culture and now we will
defeat woke
radicalism and a continuation of
communism because that's what this is
heading for
we will defeat it
with the sheer power real historical
scholar
an american
[Applause]
they might not they may not believe in
the destiny of america i really don't
believe in many ways they love our
country but we do and we are not going
to let anybody take that love away
we know that there is no mountain we
cannot climb there is no summit we
cannot reach and there is no challenge
we cannot meet
we are americans and the future
belongs to us we are going to have a
great future we are going to turn this
mess around this is a horrible thing
that's happening to our country
we're left at all over the world we're
not going to be left at anymore they're
laughing at the rally actually horrible
thing and it's going to go on for a
while
but we've got to end it we cannot let
this happen they're destroying our
country
we will not bend we will not break
we will not yield we will never give in
we will never give up we will never back
down we will never ever surrender
right
my fellow americans our movement is far
from over
in fact our fight has only just begun
in the history of our country there has
never been
a movement like this there's never been
anything that's true that's true
the senate they do okay they lose they
win a couple of votes and they're
national heroes for 50 years they're on
television talking
people run for president
and they come in second third or fourth
in one primary and their national heroes
all of a sudden
we not me we ran for president and we
won 32 states and then we did better the
second time much better
oh much much better
somebody from the congratulations sir
you just won the election difference
between
2016 and 2020. well you lost well the
difference was that in 2020 we did much
much better the rallies were bigger the
enthusiasm was more because in 2016 i
told you what we were going to do but it
was talk
in 2020 you knew that i did it
so we had a much better but we were
cheated and we it was rigged we were
cheated
but there's never been a movement like
this and you know it's funny i say it a
lot and with the fake news look at all
of them back there the fake news is back
there
they never ever question it
there's barely any media there that's
the funny thing it's like mostly
right-wing media actually
but i say this is the greatest rally in
the history of our country this is the
greatest movement in the history
greatest rally
this rally's never been anything like it
and it's probably the greatest movement
in the history of our world it's
probably
this movement call it make america great
again call it america first call it what
you will i believe it's the greatest
movement probably in the history of the
world
and it's just starting
it's just starting
we are one movement one people one
family and one glorious nation under god
so with love of our nation
swelling in our hearts and it does swell
in your hearts that's why you're
standing here in the rain listening to
this person you're saying darling it's
raining let's go home but nobody is
leaving all the way back hundreds and
like football fields behind
people have actually been heading out
for an hour
darling it's raining
but they say we're not going home
because we love our country but it's
swelling in our hearts the spirit of
america
is stirring ourselves
and i say these words to you and you've
heard these words before oh no in some
cases
many times before
we will make america powerful again
we will make america wealthy again
yeah
we will make america strong again
we will make america despite what you're
seeing today
so sad and so pathetic
we will make america proud again
we're still going yeah america safe
again
and you know what it is
we will make america great again thank
you alabama god bless you all thank you
thank you very much
and then they did dumps they call them
dumps big massive dumps what a day
in michigan and pennsylvania
[Music]
all right anyway
this country for election integrity and
for you and i so there it is it's all
very very stupid it's just incredibly
dumb um but trump is doing it and the
crowd seems to sort of be loving it
except when they are bored
um i appreciate not only everybody who
joined the stream today but we set a
record at least for the last six months
you know but the capital riots the
election night etc we were doing numbers
up here that are crazy in the four three
four hundreds but we haven't seen
anything like this for a very long time
and i want to say thank you to justin
petchey who just signed up on my website
and his new member number 270 how poetic
that is the exact number of electoral
votes that a presidential candidate
needs to become president it's the
number that donald trump
failed to get
failed to get
but it is extraordinarily
extraordinarily exciting so take
advantage of that coupon code that code
is
16 for 16.
we've done it all
let's raid who are we going to raid oh i
don't know
you know what just because of the
controversy
let's go and raid hassan over on twitch
it's been a pleasure being with all of
you today we did our calls
we did everything we really did
everything
um and we're gonna go over to uh hassan
and
um maybe i'll send him a couple bucks
for the mortgage as well myself alright
everybody thank you so much we'll see
everybody very very soon
you